HI GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE I FEEL LIKE I KILL THE
CONVERSATION I WALKED IN.
WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT THAT FORMAL --
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND APPRECIATE
EVERYONE OF BEING HERE TODAY FOR
THE ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE ON
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY FOR THE
MIDDLE AND WORKING CLASS --
BEFORE WE BEGIN I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO THINK THIS CYNICAL
HOUSING COMMISSION -- WHO ARE
HOST THIS AFTERNOON -- I WILL
I'M PUBLIC BIAS IS A FORMER
BOARD MEMBER THIS ORGANIZATION --
I THINK WE HAVE A PRETTY
PHENOMENAL HOW THE COMMISSION
HERE IN SAN DIEGO -- IN A MINUTE
NOW YOU WILL PARTNER IN THE
CONSTRUCTION AND ADMINISTRATION
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING --
THROUGHOUT SAN DIEGO.
THE RELATIONAL SO IT'S BEEN A
POLICY DRIVER SPONSORING
LEGISLATION -- TO REMOVE SOME OF
THE BARRIERS TO CONSTRUCTING
BOTH SUBSIDIZED AND MARKET RATE
HOUSING OTHERS AFFORDABLE TO
MIDDLE INCOME FAMILIES I'VE BEEN
HONOR TO COLLABORATE -- WITH BIG
GENTRY AND HIS TEAM -- FOR OVER
A DECADE -- AND SINCERELY
APPRECIATE THEIR PARTNERSHIP --
I ALSO WANTED KNOWLEDGE I KNOW
HE'S NOT HERE TODAY JEFF DAVIS --
THE HOUSING COMMISSION EXECUTIVE
VICE PRESIDENT WE ARE JOINED BY
US TO KEEP THE DAY ALL DOUBT --
WHO IS HERE FROM THE COMMISSION
J. AS TO KEEP FOR BEING HERE --
AS WELL AS C. K. WOULD ANY
INJURIES IDEA OF WHO HELPED TO
ORGANIZE TODAY'S MEETING I
BELIEVE -- I IS NOT ALWAYS EASY
TO FIND A PLACE TO HOST THESE
KIND OF THINGS THAT AWAITED
SUCCESSFUL TO THE PUBLIC SO WHEN
WE FIND FOLKS ARE WANT TO DO
THAT WE REALLY WANT EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION -- SO TODAY WE'RE
GONNA LOOK AT SOME OF THE
STRATEGIES FOR CREATING NEW
HOUSING THAT IS AFFORDABLE TO
WORKING AND MIDDLE CLASS
HOUSEHOLDS.
AS LUGS EXPLORING THE MYSTERY
MINE ACT -- IT AS IT'S
IMPLEMENTED AND HOW MIDDLE
INCOME HOUSING PRODUCTION CAN
HELP CALIFORNIA MEET ITS
AMBITIOUS CLIMATE GOALS.
AT TODAY'S HEARING IS BEING LIVE
STREAMED.
VIA THE ASSEMBLY'S WEBSITE -- AS
WELL AS ON FACEBOOK -- MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE SELECT
COMMITTEE -- WHO ARE NOT ABLE TO
JOIN US HERE TODAY WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VIEW THE HEARING
IN ITS ENTIRETY -- ONLINE --
THIS PROBABLY ALSO WHY SHOULD
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION TO OUR
SPEAKER ANTHONY RENDON OPERA
HOME SELECT COMMITTEES -- ARE
EITHER AUTHORIZED OR NOT -- HIS
WILLINGNESS TO CONTINUE ALLOW
THIS COMMITTEE TO OPERATE -- NOW
IN ITS THIRD YEAR -- IS A
REFLECTION OF THE PRIORITY HE'S
PLACED ON HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
FOR CALIFORNIANS -- SO OUR
PANELISTS WILL HAVE SEVEN TO TEN
MINUTES EACH TO PRESENT -- SO BE
HERE FROM -- MY OFFICE WILL BE
HELPING US TO KEEP TIME SOCIALLY
A TIME KEEPER JUST LOOK FOR HER
FOR A GUIDE IF YOU FEEL LIKE YOU --
MAY STILL HAVE A LOT OF TIME TO
FIND OUT THAT YOU DON'T -- IN
WITH THAT -- WE WILL I'M SORRY
WE HAVE WELL THREE CANDLES AND
THEN FOR ANY NUMBER THE PUBLIC
WHO WISHES TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE WE TAKE UP PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE END OF THE
HEARING -- SO -- JUST -- THOUGH
THAT'S HOW WE'LL HANDLE THAT I'M
PROUD OPPORTUNITY JUST LINE UP
HERE AT THE DÍAS I WITH THAT
WE'LL DIVE RIGHT IN WITH OUR
FIRST PANEL ON THE USE OF STATE
AND LOCAL AGENCIES SURPLUS LAND.
FOR MIDDLE INCOME AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING -- WITH THIS BILL WOULD
HERE HERE TO SPEAK WITH US ON
THE FIRST PANEL IS JEAN DE AS
FOR MEMBERS IN THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST NETWORK.
THEN WE'LL HEAR FROM JASON
KENNEY OF CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
GENERAL SERVICES SO SASHA WAS
GOT WAS COUNTY FROM -- CALLOUSLY
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING COMMITTEE
ON IT AND LAST BUT CERTAINLY NOT
LEAST MY FRIEND POGGIBONSI THE
CEO OF THAT CITY THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSIT SYSTEM.
THE G. THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR INVITING
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LAND
TRUST NETWORK TO US SPEAK ON
THIS VERY IMPORTANT TOPIC.
AND JUST TODAY THE NONPROFIT
QUARTERLY MAGAZINE PUBLISHED AN
ARTICLE IT'S VERY TIMELY THE
HEADLINE IS.
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST COME OF AGE
BLOW OUT THE CANDLES AND WE THE
LAND TRUST NETWORK REPRESENTS
SEVERAL COMMUNITY LAND TRUST
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA FROM SAN
DIEGO TO NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
HUMBLE COUNTY.
COLLECTIVELY COMMUNITY LAND
TRUSTS ARE PROVIDED OVER EIGHT
HUNDRED HOMES WITH OVER THIRTEEN
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY PLANNED.
OVER TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION IN ASSETS THEY PROVIDED
SINGLE FAMILY MULTI FAMILY
LIMITED EQUITY CALL UPS IN
SUPPORT OF HOUSING.
URBAN AGRICULTURE AND WORKFORCE
TRAINING.
AS IT IS THIS.
SELECT COMMITTEE RECOGNIZES.
AFFORDABILITY AFFECTS MODERATE
INCOME FAMILIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WHAT'S A WHAT'S
IMPORTANT IS NOT BEING ABLE TO
READ.
EACH OF THE NUMBERS BUT TO LOOK
AT THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
LEFT HAND BARS AND THESE BARS
HERE.
THIS IS THE INCOME NEEDED TO
AFFORD THE MEDIAN PRICED HOME IN
SAN FRANCISCO.
LOS ANGELES OXNARD THOUSAND OAKS
CENTER OF SAN DIEGO CARLSBAD
THIS IS A PROBLEM AND THESE ARE
STE TYPICAL SALARIES -- FOR FOR
FIREMEN FOR POLICE FOR TEACHERS
FOR THE PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN
THESE COMMUNITIES THIS IS A
PROBLEM THAT AFFECTS.
ALL CALIFORNIANS.
HOW TO SEAL TEES?
ADDRESSED PRODUCTION AND
PRESERVATION.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE HOUSING
LADDER ON THE RIGHT HAND SIDE.
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST ENHANCE
MOBILITY FROM SUPPORT OF RENTAL
TO MARKET OWNERSHIP.
WE SORT OF TAKE THE BRIDGE FROM
HOMELESSNESS IN SUPPORT OF
HOUSING TO MARKET RATE HOUSING.
COMMUNITY LAND TRUSTS GENERALLY
PROVIDE HOUSING FOR LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
[INAUDIBLE]
WE CONSTRUCT.
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES ARE MULTI
FAMILY HOMES.
WE ASSUME DE DISTRICT HOMES --
DENSITY BONUS HOMES INCLUSIONARY
HOUSING UNITS AND STORE THEM.
AND WE ALSO PROVIDE PRODUCTION
OF LIMITED EQUITY CALL UPS AND
OTHER FORMS OF RENTAL HOMES.
WE ALSO PRESERVE AND PROTECT.
EXISTING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
STOCK.
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST OWNERSHIP
PRESERVES CONTROL PERMANENTLY
INTO THE FUTURE TO RESELL
RESTRICTIONS THAT WE HAVE IN OUR
GROUND LEASES.
CAN PROVIDE STORAGE OF OF
COMMUNITY ASSETS.
CLT IS A LOT OF THEM STARTED BY
ACQUIRING FORECLOSED HOMES AND
WE HAVING THEM.
AND PUTTING THEM INTO THE
PERMANENT AFFORDABILITY OF
PORTFOLIO.
THE PLACING NEW AND EXISTING.
DEED RESTRICTED HOMES WILL
CONVERT THOSE DEED RESTRICTED
ARE PROVISIONS THAT TYPICALLY
EXPIRE AFTER PERIOD FORTY FIVE
FIFTY YEARS.
INTO PERMANENT AFFORDABILITY
I'LL TALK ABOUT THAT IN JUST A
MINUTE -- SHIELDS IS ALSO
PROVIDE OTHER SORTS OF SERVICES
BUT THE PRIMARY FOCUS IS HOUSING.
THE BASIC COMMUNITY LATIMES
MODEL.
IS DUE OWNERSHIP.
THE COMMUNITY LAND TRUST WILL
ALWAYS RETAIN OWNERSHIP OF THE
LAND.
THE BASIC MODEL IS THE COMMUNITY
LAND TRUST WILL.
IMPROVE FOR CHOIR HOME CELL AT
HOME SUBJECT TO NINETY NINE YOUR
GROUND PLEASE.
THAT PROVIDES PERPETUAL
AFFORDABILITY THROUGH THE RESALE
RESTRICTIONS.
WE PROVIDE STEWARDSHIP WE
REQUIRED HOME BUYERS KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE GETTING INTO AND PROVIDE
SUPPORT ANIMAL TALK ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF THAT IN JUST A A
PREVIOUS AND SUBSEQUENT SLIDE.
THERE'S ALSO COMMUNITY
PARTICIPATION GENERALLY ONE
THIRD OF THE BOARD FOR CMT'S
COME FROM OWNERSHIP FROM THE
OWNERS OF THE COMMUNITY LAND
TRUST OHMS.
AND A CHANCE TO BE A MORE
EFFICIENT SOME CITIES AND OTHER
PUBLIC HOUSING PROGRAMS -- IT
MAY BE A ONE TIME SUBSIDY FOR
PLANNED FOR EXAMPLE THAT MIGHT
BE PROVIDED BY SURPLUS PROPERTY.
BUT TYPICALLY THERE'S NO OTHER
FORM OF SUBSIDY.
I'M LIKE DOWN PAYMENT ASSISTANCE
WERE IN A RISING MARKET.
GREATER AND GREATER SUBSIDY IS
REQUIRED TO RETAIN THAT SAME
LEVEL OF AFFORDABILITY.
AND ALSO I MENTIONED THE DEED
RESTRICTED HOMES.
I WOULD HAVE A TIME LIMIT.
AND WITH WITH THE COMMUNITY LAND
TRUST MODEL IT'S A PERPETUAL
[INAUDIBLE]
COMMUNITY OWNERSHIP.
JERRY LAI TRUSTED TYPICALLY FIVE
OH ONE C. THREE SECOND BE
STANDALONE SIMILAR TO THE SAN
DIEGO COMMUNITY LAND TRUST.
THEY CAN BE CREATURES OF A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT LIKE YOU'RE BUYING
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST OR MORE
MORE WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS
COLLABORATIONS WITH OTHER GROUPS
SUCH AS HABITAT FOR HUMANITY.
WE THINK THIS IS A A REAL AREA
FOR EXPLORING IN THE FUTURE
BECAUSE IT BRINGS THE BEST OF
BOTH MODELS TOGETHER.
ON THERE SOME INFORMATION THERE
SOME LINKS IN TERMS OF WHERE TO
GET MORE INFORMATION.
I MENTIONED THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE STORAGE OF THE LAND TRUST --
YOU MOST OF OUR HOME BUYERS ARE
A FIRST TIME HOME BUYERS THROUGH
THE FIRST.
THE CRISIS THAT WE HAVE IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TEN THE FOURTH
QUARTER THE MIDDLE OF THE
HOUSING CRISIS.
THE COMMUNITY LAND TRUST
MORTGAGES WERE A TINY TINY
FRACTION OF EVEN PRIME MORTGAGES
IN TERMS OF SERVICE
DELINQUENCIES ARE FORECLOSURES.
THAT'S A FUNCTION OF THE
STEWARDSHIP.
SO ON TO WHAT CAN BE DONE TO
HELP LEGISLATION AND POLICIES TO
SUPPORT AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
OF COURSE REDUCING COSTS FOR LOW
AND MODERATE INCOME HOME
DEVELOPMENT AND I KNOW BUT A
SUBSEQUENT.
PANEL WILL TALK ABOUT
STREAMLINING THE APPROVAL
PROCESS.
ANOTHER VERY IMPORTANT ASPECT --
PORT ONE OF THE IMPORTANT WAYS
TO DO THAT.
IS -- SB ONE NINETY SIX WHICH IS
CURRENTLY IN THE ASSEMBLY.
WHICH WOULD EXPAND THE WELFARE
EXEMPTION DURING CONSTRUCTION
FOR COMMUNITY LAND TRUST
PROJECTS.
MARTIN JOHN TO HELP REDUCE THE
COST.
ANOTHER ATTACK AREAS TO IMPROVE
ACCESS TO FINANCIAL RESOURCES.
FOR NONPROFIT PROVIDERS LIKE
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST.
CAPACITY GRANTS OR FUNDS FOR PRE
DEVELOPMENT AND CONSTRUCTION
SIMILAR TO THE PROP ONE AND CAL
HOME -- PROGRAM THAT IS
CURRENTLY ARE GOING THROUGH THE
DEREGULATION PHASE.
AND OR TO IMPROVE ACCESS TO RAW
MATERIALS AND THAT'S WHERE WE
TALK ABOUT SURPLUS PROPERTIES --
SURPLUS PROP PROPERTY IS A RAW
MATERIAL FOR HOUSING YOU NEED
PROPERTY TO BUILD A HOUSING.
A COUPLE OF BILLS THAT ARE VERY
IMPORTANT IN THIS LEGISLATION
ARE SB SIX TO PROVIDE A
CENTRALIZED DATABASE OF
AVAILABLE SURPLUS PROPERTIES.
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE INVENTORY IS
SO WE KNOW.
WHERE TO GO TO TRY TO FIND THOSE
RESOURCES?
ALSO THE PRIORITY FOR
DEVELOPMENT OF LOW AND MODERATE
INCOMES -- THERE THERE'S A B.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX THAT IS
GOING TO THE ASSEMBLY AND I
THINK IS NOW WE ARE GOING TO THE
SENATE.
SO THINGS LIKE THAT ARE VERY
IMPORTANT IN TERMS OF OF HELPING
COMMUNITY LAND TRUSTS AND OTHER
NON PROFITS GET ACCESS TO THE
RAW MATERIAL.
ALSO WHAT'S IMPORTANT IS TO
ENSURE THAT LEGISLATION AND
POLICY IMPLEMENTATION CONSIDERS
COMMUNITY LAND TRUSTS EXPLICITLY.
AS AN IMPORTANT PROVIDER OF LOW
AND MODERATE INCOME HOMES
INCLUDING OWNERSHIP [INAUDIBLE]
FOR EXAMPLE.
IT MAY BE IMPORTANT IT IS
IMPORTANT TO INCLUDE
SPECIFICALLY AND DEFINITION OF
COMMUNITY LAND TRUSTS.
WITHIN THE DEFINITION OF HOUSING
SPONSOR.
RIGHT NOW IT'S NOT CLEAR -- AND
I THINK IT WOULD HELP TO
RECOGNIZE COMMUNITY LAND TRUSTS.
AS AN IMPORTANT TOOL IN
PROVIDING EXPANDING.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME FAMILIES.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE IS SUCH A NINE
OF OF BABY.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX THAT DOES
PROVIDE.
THAT A PRIORITY BE GIVEN IN
TERMS OF A CONFLICT OF TWO
PROPOSALS THAT ARE EQUAL.
THE PRIORITY BE GIVEN TO THE
MAXIMUM NUMBER OF ROOFS.
OR THE DEEPEST INCOME LEVEL
SERVED.
THAT I THINK.
ON INTENTIONALLY DISADVANTAGES
LOW AND MODERATE OWNERSHIP.
DUE TO THE DIFFERENT ECONOMICS
AND THE FEASIBILITY OF OWNERSHIP
PROJECTS.
OWNERSHIP PROJECTS GENERALLY
DON'T HAVE THE SAME ACCESS TO
SUBSIDIES LIKE TAX CREDITS LIKE
LOW INCOME RENTAL DOES.
SO WE SHOULD JUST BE AWARE WHEN
WE MAKE -- PROVISIONS LIKE THIS
THAT WE DON'T INADVERTENTLY
DISADVANTAGE LOW AND MODERATE
INCOME OWNERSHIP PROJECTS.
THANK YOU.
NOW AND AGAIN THERE'S MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT -- COMMUNITY
LAND TRUSTS THROUGH THE LINKS
THERE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH REPRESENTATION
VERY EFFICIENTLY DELIVERED A
LOTS OF GOOD INFORMATION ON THAT
IT THANKS THAT STUFF -- THE REST
OF THE PRESENTATIONS -- CAN YOU
REPEAT THE ARTICLE CAME OUT
TODAY YES WE GET THAT OUT TO OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YEAH YEAH YEAH YEAH IT'S THE ON
THE NONPROFIT QUARTERLY.
AND IT JUST CAME OUT TODAY I
JUST GOT THE ARTICLE TODAY AND
IS COMMUNITY LAND TRUSTS COME OF
AGE.
BLOW OUT THE CANDLES AND WISH
FOR A POLICY AGENDA.
IT'S A VERY GOOD ARTICLE --
PROVIDING A SYNOPSIS OF THE
COMMUNITY LANDFILLS MOVEMENT AND
HOW THEY'VE GROWN AND REALLY
BECOME A FORCE AND EXPANDING LOW
AND MODERATE INCOME.
HOUSING THAT'S QUITE THE TITLE.
FOR THIS SESSION -- AND THEN FOR
YOUR SECOND SIDE ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS WHEN I WAS REACTIVE
THIS LOOKING AT LAST NIGHT IS
THAT -- IN THE NORTHEAST -- IT'S
FAIRLY NEW IN THE WEST COAST
ESPECIALLY IN CALIFORNIA SO IT
TAKES SOME TIME I THINK FOR
COMMUNITIES TO UNDERSTAND HOW
COMMUNITY LAND TRUSTS CAN HELP.
SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
AND ONE OF THEM ONE OF THE IDEA
WHEN WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
COMMITTEE LAND TRUST IT THERE'S
THIS GREAT RECOGNITION THAT IT'S
A WONDERFUL MODEL IS ALWAYS
WONDERFUL THINGS.
SO WE THINK THAT WE CAN JUST
CREATE A COMMUNITY LAND TRUST.
TRANSFER ALL THE PROBLEMS TO THE
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST BUT NOT
PROVIDE THE RESOURCES FOR THEM
TO DO IT SO.
THAT THAT'S YOU KNOW THAT'S ONE
OF THINGS WE'RE TRYING TO DO
WITH AND EXPAND THE COMMUNITY
LAND TRUST NETWORK THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA GET MORE COMMUNITIES
INVOLVED.
AND I WOULD SAY THEY'RE PROBABLY
THREE OR FOUR COMMUNITY LAND
TRUST THAT HAVE BEEN ADDED JUST
EACH YEAR IN THE LAST THREE OR
FOUR YEARS SO IT IS GROWING IN
CALIFORNIA.
IMPORTANT THE NEXT SLIDE IN
TERMS OF THAT THAT THE INCOMING
NEEDED PEACE I BECAUSE POSTED
NECESSARILY MAKE IT OUT ON THE
ON THIS ON THE GRAPH.
THE FIRST OF IS DECEPTIVE IT
KIND OF LOOKS LIKE SAN DIEGO
MIGHT BE A BARGAIN AND I'VE MADE
RIGHT BY COMPARISON THE SAN
FRANCISCO PROCESS TRUE BUT YOU
KNOW THAT THAT'S A GOAL
COMFORTED HE'S GETTING IN TRYING
TO FIND A PLACE ALLEN -- BUT
THOSE THE ANNUAL INCOME NEED IT
IS BASED ON A 10% DOWN PAYMENT
THE GRAPH RIGHT OUT WILL WANT TO
THE LEFT HAND COLUMN IS 10% DOWN
PAYMENT THE ONE NEXT TO IT WHICH
HAS A SLIGHTLY HIGHER INCOME
REQUIREMENT IS A 3% DOWN PAYMENT.
SO YOU'RE GIVING -- AND TO PUT
TO THE PURCHASE OF A HOME RIGHT
OKAY -- AND THEN I JUST LOVE THE
HOUSING LADDER ON YOUR NEXT
SLIDE AND IF WE CAN BRING THAT
ONE UP BUT YOU KNOW I THINK
OFTEN AND I THINK LEASE LOWS --
PRESENTATION LATER REALLY
ILLUSTRATE THE FACT THEY ARE
LATTER DOESN'T HAVE SLOTS -- IN
THE MIDDLE ANY LONGER AND YOU
HAVE A HUGE YAWNING GAP BETWEEN
THE TOP AND A LOT OF THE BOTTOM
OF THE LADDER -- I'M GRATEFUL
THAT YOU KIND OF PAINT THAT
PICTURE BECAUSE PEOPLE DO YOU
SEE CONSTRUCTION IN THE
COMMUNITY AND THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY THAT'S NOT TO SAY
DIRECTLY BENEFITING THEN WE'RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT.
THE FOCUS OF THIS COMMITTEE
WHICH IS AGAIN SORT OF BILLION
THAT MIDDLE SECTION FOR THE WORK
THAT YOU'RE DOING.
WITH REGARD TO THE TO THE
FORMATION YOU MENTIONED THAT THE
OF THE PROPERTY OWNERSHIP IS
RETAINED BY THE LAND TRUST.
IS IT FAIR TO CALL THIS ALMOST
LIKE A LIKE A IS A TRAILER PARK
CAMINO MOBILE HOMES HAVE A BIT A
STIGMA MILITANT -- TO IT'S IT'S
A USE OF THE VEHICLE YOU KNOW
FOR NO PUN INTENDED -- FOR FOR
THE GROW THE WEALTH RIGHT IN THE
HOMEOWNERSHIP AND WHAT I WAS
INTENDED TO GO WELL.
NEVER OWN THE ACTUAL LAND RIGHT
RIGHT SO HOW DOES SOMEONE WHO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROGRAM HOW
DO YOU DAY BESIDES THE OBVIOUS
TO BE ABLE TO GET A PRICE POINT
THEY CAN AFFORD.
HOW DOES THIS WORK FOR THEIR
FAMILY TO BILL GENERATIONAL OFF
THAT ALLOWS THEM TO YOU KNOW BE
REALIZED?
BETWEEN THE WERE TOLD RUSSIA
EXCELLENT QUESTION.
THE THE RESALE FORMULA CAN VERY
FROM MY INTEREST IN ONE OF THE
GREAT THINGS ABOUT THE COMMUNITY
ELECTIONS MODEL IS ITS FLEXIBLE
AND IT CAN BE ADAPTED TO LOCAL
SITUATIONS.
OF FOR EXAMPLE THE CALIFORNIA IN
THE SAN DIEGO COMMUNITY LAND
TRUST THEIR RESALE FORMULAS TIED
TO CHANGES IN ANY OF MY SO A
FAMILY THE BUYS A COMMUNITY LAND
TRUST OHMS THROUGH THE SAN DIEGO
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST.
THEY THEY CAN SELL ANY TIME THEY
WANT THERE'S NO RESTRICTION ON
WHEN THEY SELL.
BUT IF IF THE TRUST HAD PRICE
THE HOME SO WAS AFFORDABLE TO
FOUNDING EARNING A HARPER 100%
OF SAN DIEGO AREA MEDIAN INCOME.
WHEN THEY GO TO SELL IT HAS TO
BE AFFORDABLE TO A FAMILY AT
THAT POINT IN TIME?
EARNING A 100% OF THE AIRLINE SO
WHATEVER CHANGE IN ANY OF MY IS
THAT'S THE FIRST LEVEL OF EQUITY
GROWTH THAT THEY HAVE -- IN
ADDITION THEN I HAVE OWNERSHIP
WHICH IS AT AND WE WILL ONLY
PERMIT FIXED RATE THIRTY YEAR
MORTGAGES SO THERE'S NO VARIABLE
RATE OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT SO WE
FIX THEIR HOUSING COSTS I'M LIKE
RENTAL.
AYE WEATHER CHARTS AND I'VE DONE
THAT SHOW A COMPARISON BETWEEN.
RENT EVEN IN THE WORLD EVEN
DURING THE HOUSING CRISIS RENT
GOES UP.
RAMPING RANT IS NEGATIVE EQUITY.
HERE.
IS NOT THE SAME GROWTH IS IF YOU
HAVE THE GOOD LUCK TO BUY A HOME
AND IT WAS LOW MARKET RATE HOME
AND SO WHEN IT WAS FINE YEAH BUT
YOU ALSO DON'T HAVE THE RISK.
OF BUYING ONE AT THE BEACON
SELLING AND LOSING 50% OF YOUR
EQUITY.
SO IT IS SLOW BUT STEADY AND IT
DOES PROVIDE FOR EQUITY GROW SEE
OKAY SO THE EQUITY THAT IS K.
DOES NOT PERTAIN BY THAT LAND
TRUST IS RETAINED BY THE OWNER
THAT'S RIGHT IF THEY WANT OKAY --
I WAS VERY HIGH LIKE THE
PERPETUAL AFFORDABILITY PIECE OF
THE MODEL -- FOR THOSE THAT WERE
A LOT ABOUT RETAINING YOU KNOW
WHAT WE'RE OFTEN INTERESTED IN
BUILDING NEW SUBSIDIZE UNITS.
BUT THE RETAINING AND AND AND ON
DAHLE GOING TO PORTABILITY OF
PROJECTS THAT THAT TIME OUT THIS
THIS MODEL SOLVE THAT PARTICULAR
PROBLEM ISN'T THAT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I TRY TO DO IS WORK
WITH DEVELOPERS WHEN THEY HAVE
INCLUSIONARY UNITS OR DEED
RESTRICTED UNITS OR
MUNICIPALITIES OR MANAGING.
THOSE PROGRAMS WHEN ONE OF THOSE
UNITS BECOMES AVAILABLE.
PUT IT IN OUR OUR PORTFOLIO
BECAUSE THEN IT BECOMES
PERMANENTLY AFFORDABLE THROUGH
THE NINETY NINE YOUR RENEWABLE
FAMILIES.
JUST.
AND I'M GRATEFUL FOR YOUR BOOKS
ARE WRAPPING UP WITH THE THE
LEGISLATION THAT WORK ALL THESE
ARE ACTIVE BILLS YES -- BY GOOD
AUTHOR SO I THINK YOU STAND A
GOOD CHANCE SOMEBODY'S BECOMING
LAW -- THERE IS A DIFFERENCE
JUST -- ON THAT WHAT WITH THE
ONE THAT POPPED OUT SEEING I
THINK YOU'RE ALLUDING TO AS A
POTENTIAL PIECE OF THE
LEGISLATIVE IDEA FOR FUTURE
LEGISLATIVE SESSION.
IS INCLUDING CLT THE DEFINITION
OF A HOUSING SPONSORED THAT IS
WRONG INTRODUCED LEGISLATION
THAT IS RIGHT -- YEAH YEAH I'M
SORRY THERE THERE IS REGULATION
FOR EXAMPLE THE REGULATIONS THAT
ARE BEING PROMULGATED NOW IN
TERMS OF THE HOME PROGRAM -- THE
THE CAL HOME PROGRAM YEAH --
WE'VE ACTUALLY SUBMITTED
COMMENTS SUGGESTING THAT THEY
MAKE A IN THE IN THE DEFINITIONS
FOR THEM PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY ON
THE DEFINING COMMUNITY LAND
TRUSTS.
WHEN THERE ARE OTHER FUNDING
SOURCES THAT THEY COULD USE THIS
GUIDANCE YES?
OKAY WE'LL KEEP THIS POST ON IT.
THAT'S DONE BY REGULATION IF NOT
MAYBE BY LEGISLATION WE SHOULD
LOOK FOR IT IS FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY LEGISLATIVE YEAR.
I THINK THAT SOUNDS REASONABLE --
AND I WAS ABLE TO PROBLEMS BILLS
ALREADY SO YOU CAN.
MAKE -- G. A. LAST COMMENTS
BEFORE ABOUT BUT THE MOVE TO THE
NEXT AS A NO JUST GET OTHER
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS IT MAY NOT A
VOTE VOTED ON THESE BILLS YEAH
PLEASE VOTE FOR THEM.
I I KNOW THAT -- ONE NINETY SIX
IS VERY IMPORTANT TO US AND
THAT'S IN THE ASSEMBLY RIGHT NOW
SO HOPEFULLY THAT WILL GET TO
THE FOR VERY SOON.
ALL YOU KNOW THE TRIGGERS A
QUESTION I'M GLAD YOU SAID THAT --
WE TOOK OUR OFTEN WITH PUBLIC
SUBSIDY OF PUBLIC INVESTMENT IN
PARTICULAR PROJECTS COMES --
WORKER -- GUIDELINES AND LEVELS
PAY THINGS OF THAT NATURE IS
THAT TRUE FOR LAND TRUSTS -- I
THINK IT DEPENDS ON THE SPECIFIC
SOURCES OF FUNDS PROVIDED TO OUR
COMMUNITY LAND TRUSTS -- TO SOME --
SOME FORMS OF OF SUBSIDY WOULD
REQUIRE FOR EXAMPLE -- IN
CERTAIN WAYS RESTRICTIONS ARE.
INVITING US ABSOLUTELY CHASING
CARRYING MY COME ON DOWN.
AND IS SUCH AS MEDICAL PERCENT
WHICH IN EITHER OF THAT IS IN
CALIFORNIA PART OF GENERAL
SERVICES REAL ESTATE.
DIVISION.
IS MAYBE NOT I WAS LOOKING FOR
US TO TODAY NO PRESSURE.
YEAH BARS REALLY HIGH THANK YOU.
WELL IN IN JEAN DID SET THE BAR
FOR EFFICIENT PRESENTATION TEARS --
I'LL DO MY BEST THANK YOU -- SO
WE OBVIOUSLY THE ADMINISTRATION
WANTS TO DO ITS PART -- AND
DRIVING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT ACROSS THE STATE AND
SO EXECUTIVE ORDER AND SIX
NINETEEN AS WE ARE TALK ABOUT
TODAY -- UNDER A COUPLE THINGS
ONE JUST KIND OF GIVE A QUICK
BRIEF -- HIGHLIGHTS OF THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER AND THERE'S ONE
THING I WANT TO FOCUS ON WHICH
IS THE DISTINCTION BETWEEN
SURPLUS AND ACCESS PROPERTY.
AS PARTICULARLY RELEVANT FOR
THIS BECAUSE THIS IS A REALLY A
FIRST OF ITS KIND OF PROCESS
THAT WE'RE GOING THROUGH -- AND
WE'LL TALK ABOUT KIND OF THE THE
ACTUAL IMPLEMENTATION STEPS AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER AND WHEREAS WITH
THAT SPECIFICALLY AND THEN THE
RESULTS TO DATE -- AND KIND OF
WHAT THE THE THE FUTURE LOOKS
LIKE FOR US.
SO -- IN TERMS OF THIS THIS
ACCESS OUR CLOSEST ENGINE SO
STATE PROPERTY IS IS OWNED BY
THE STATE BUT IT'S HELD IN TRUST
BY DEPARTMENTS AND WE COULD BE
COULD BE TERM THAT HAVING
JURISDICTION OVER A PIECE OF
PROPERTY -- AND SO DEPARTMENTS
HAVE JURISDICTION OVER STATE
PROPERTY AND THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO
BE USING IT FOR THEIR TO EXECUTE
THEIR MISSION -- STATE HOSPITALS
HAVE IT TO TREAT PATIENTS -- CHP
OFFICERS HAVE IT TO PROVIDE
SERVICE TO THE COMMUNITY CENTER --
AS THOSE PROPERTIES -- OF NO
LONGER MEET THEIR NEEDS WHEN
THEY NEED TO RELOCATE SUPPORTING
IT DOWNSIZE FOR THE LEGISLATURE
HAS CHANGED THE MISSION IN SOME
WAY SHAPE OR FORM.
THE WAY IT WORKS IN STATUTE IS
THAT THEY WOULD DECLARE THE
PROPERTY ACCESS AND THAT WOULD
TRIGGER DG HAS TO COME IN AND
BEGIN WORKING ON A DISPOSITION
PROCESS.
THAT COULD BE TRANSFERRED TO
THIS AGENCY IT COULD BE -- A
LONG TERM LEASE OR SOME SORT
DEVELOPMENT WHICH IS DONE IN THE
PAST OR IT COULD BE A SALE
PROCESS GOING THROUGH A
LEGISLATION TO BE AUTHORIZES
SURPLUS -- HISTORICALLY WE GET
ONE TWO THREE AND FOUR IS A BIG
YEAR OF PROPERTIES DECLARED
ACCESS BY DEPARTMENTS -- IT
REALLY IS NOT A VOLUMINOUS
PROCESS SO WHAT THIS EXECUTIVE
ORDER REPORTERS TO DO WAS TO GO
THROUGH AND SORT OF TO A
PROACTIVE REVIEW OF STATE
PROPERTY -- SO WE HAD A TEAM OF
NINE PEOPLE LOOK AT FORTY FOUR
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY PARCELS ACROSS THE STATE --
WHICH I WILL DOUBLE TALK ABOUT
THE RESULT IN A SACK -- BUT IN
ADDITION TO THAT REVIEW -- THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER REQUIRES US TO
TAKE A VERY SYSTEMATIC APPROACH --
WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE BEING LIKE A
FINAL -- WE DO INITIAL INVENTORY
ALL THE WAY DOWN TO PRIORITIZE
SITES FOR DEVELOPMENT -- THESE
GIVE ORDER ALSO -- FOCUSES ON
INNOVATIVE EQUITABLE AND
SUSTAINABLE CONSTRUCTION
APPROACHES -- THERE IS A SINCERE
DESIRE TO PARTNER WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN THESE
DEVELOPMENTS RECOGNIZING THAT
ANYTHING WE BUILD IS GOING TO BE
IN SOMEONE'S COMMUNITY -- AND IF
IF YOU READ EXECUTIVE ORDER YOU
SEE A LOT OF EXPEDITED DATES WE
WANT TO BUILD THIS WE WANT ALL
THESE THINGS FAST.
SO WHAT ARE PROCESS STEPS SO ONE
VISUAL INVENTORY -- AND THAT HAS
BEEN COMPLETED -- PARTNERING
TOGETHER H. C. D. AND D. G. S.
HAVE CREATED A SCREENING TOOL --
THAT THOSE PARCELS HAVE BEEN
UNDERGONE IN TERMS OF HELPING US
SORT OF UNDERSTAND YES SOMETHING
MIGHT BE DEVELOPING BOWL BUT IS
IT APPROPRIATE FOR HOUSING --
AND THEN THE NEXT BIG STEP WAS
TAKEN AWHILE IS TO ACTUALLY GO
THROUGH DEPARTMENTAL BETTING --
WE'VE LOOKED AT PARCELS THAT
THAT -- THAT COULD BE OVER
HOUSING THAT WERE APPROPRIATE
FOR THE BILL FOR HOUSING -- BUT
I DIDN'T MEAN THAT THE SITE
DIDN'T HAVE A MILLION
ENCUMBRANCES ON IT THAT DIDN'T
MEAN THAT THE SITE WAS INTO SHE
TO THE STATE TWENTY FIVE YEARS
AGO FOR A PARTICULAR PURPOSE --
IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT -- THAT
APARTMENT ACTUALLY WASN'T USING
IT JUST IN TIME WE EVALUATED
THEY THEY DIDN'T SEEM TO BE --
AND SO WE WENT THROUGH A
DEPARTMENTAL VETTING PROCESS TO
GET TO SITES WHERE DEPARTMENTS
HAVE AGREED YES THIS LIKE CAN BE
DECLARED ACCESS SO WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD -- AND THAT HAS ALSO
BEEN COMPLETED JUST RECENTLY SO --
NOW WE'RE AT THE SITE
PRIVATIZATION PIECE WHAT WE'RE
GOING THROUGH AND LOOKING AT THE
NUMBER OF SITES WE HAVE ACROSS
THE STATE PRIORITIZING -- WHICH
ONES WILL GET DEVELOPED -- THE
NEXT STEPS IN THE FUTURE BEYOND
THAT WOULD BE -- TO PUBLISHER
HEAT MAP SHOWING ALL OF OUR
SITES WITH AN OVERLAY OF WHERE
HOUSING IS MOST NEEDED.
ACROSS THE STATE -- THEN WILL
TAKE THOSE -- PRIORITIZE SITES
BEGIN TO DO REAL ESTATE DUE
DILIGENCE AND THEN -- ISSUE ARE
PEAS AND ART THAT THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER HAS A DEADLINE FOR THE
FIRST OUR PIECE TO GO OUT IN
SEPTEMBER THE END OF SEPTEMBER
OF TWENTY NINETEEN SO COMING UP
VERY SOON.
SO WHAT DOES IT LOOK LIKE SO
440-003-0070 PARCELS -- THEY
WERE REVIEWED IT PRIMARILY FOR
TWO THINGS -- DEVELOPED ABILITY
AND USE SO WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
SHEA FILES WERE LOOKING AT THE
SIGHTS THEMSELVES ARE THEY OF
THE RIGHT SIZE AND WE'RE LOOKING
IN A LARGE AND SMALL -- SO LONG
AS ARE NOT LIKE STRIPS OF LAND
OR THEY UNDER FREEWAY.
ARE THEY UNDER WATER THINGS LIKE
THAT -- WE HAVE QUITE A FEW OF
THOSE BELIEVE IT OR NOT -- AND
THEN AT THE SAME POINT IN TIME
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING FOR A USAGE
SO IS IT A VACANT PARKING LOT --
IN SOME CASES WE MIGHT HAVE --
BOUGHT PROPERTY FOR A AND ET
FACILITY TWENTY YEARS AGO AND WE
ONLY DEVELOPED ON THREE QUARTERS
OF IT SO MAYBE WE COULD PARCEL
OFF THE OTHER QUARTER DEVELOP
THEIR THOSE SORTS OF THINGS --
BACK ON SCREEN DOWN TO ABOUT
THIRTEEN HUNDRED PARCELS ACROSS
THE STATE AND THE SCREENING TOOL
I MENTIONED WAS AN APPLIED AND
SOCIAL TALK ABOUT WHAT THAT TOOL
DOES AND HOW IT WAS USED IN A
SECOND -- AND THEN WE TAKE THOSE
THIRTY NINE THIRTY PARCELS AND
YOU ACTUALLY GROUP THEM INTO
SITES -- A LOT OF THEM WERE
ADJACENT OR ACROSS THE STREET
EACH OTHER SO WE WE STARTED
USING THE SITE TERMINOLOGY THERE
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY OR
SO THAT NUMBER -- GOT BIGGER AND
SMALLER -- OVER THE LAST COUPLE
OF MONTHS AS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE REACHED OUT AND ASKED US
ABOUT SITE EXERCISE WHY -- THERE
ARE CERTAIN SITES FOR EXAMPLE
THAT WE HAD TO DISCOUNTED ARE
DISCARDED -- BUT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HAD MENTIONED HEY WE
ONLY JUST A PARTIAL AND SO MAYBE
YOUR SITE ISN'T A WHOLE BUT
TOGETHER IT IS AND SO -- THE
NUMBERS FLEXED AND IT'S GONE UP
AND GOING DOWN -- AND THEN THE
THE DEPARTMENT VETTING HAS
OCCURRED AND SO AFTER -- IT
LIMITING THE SIZE I HAVE THE
BILLS ENCUMBRANCES THAT -- HOW
THE LEGITIMATE -- FUTURE
UTILIZATION -- OR OTHER
RESTRICTIONS WE ARE DOWN TO
ABOUT A HUNDRED SITES STATEWIDE.
THAT NUMBER WILL ALSO FLEX -- UP
AND DOWN WE HAVE -- SOME APPEALS
FRANKLY THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
GOING THROUGH A DEPARTMENTS --
BUT AND SOME OF THOSE SITES ARE
GONNA NATIONALLY SLOUGH OFF
MEANING WE WE LOOK AT THEM THAT
AVAILABLE MIGHT BE PROPER
HOUSING.
BUT THEY BE REALLY REALLY REALLY
REALLY HARD TO DO IS MAYBE THOSE
WILL NATURALLY FALL OFF OR GOING
OUT TO KIND OF SEE LIKE GOES BUT
FOR RIGHT NOW WE'VE GOT ABOUT A
HUNDRED SITES THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT AND THE NEXT LIGHT HERE GIVES
YOU A SENSE.
FOR JUST THE SCOPE -- THIS IS
SAN DIEGO COUNTY THIS IS EVERY
STATE ON PARCEL IN THE COUNTY --
YOU CAN GET A SENSE FOR JUST
OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE CERTAIN
THINGS THAT ARE IN.
URBAN AREAS THAT CERTAIN THINGS
THAT ARE RURAL AREAS THINGS THAT
ARE YOU KNOW PARKS LAND FORCE
LAND THINGS LIKE THAT -- SOME
NATIONALLY SCREEN THEMSELVES OUT --
THIS NEXT LIGHT IS AN EXAMPLE TO
SACRAMENTO -- THIS IS A SITE --
JUST TO THE SOUTH OF THE CAPITAL
CAPITAL THAT BIG PARK AREA OF
IT'S ACTUALLY A TGS -- OWN SITE
IT'S A PARKING LOTS AND THERE IS
A SMALL -- COMPLEX THERE THAT
USUALLY USE USE USE -- FOR
EVENTS SO WE'RE WE'RE INTERESTED
IN TAKING A SITE MAKING -- VIA
AN EXAMPLE AFFORDABLE HOUSING SO
EASY CENTS FOR KIND OF WHAT WE
HAD TO GO THROUGH VERSES THE
SIZE THAT WE'RE SEEING SOME OF
THE SITES ARE ACTUALLY QUITE
LARGE WE'VE GOT -- SITES
ADJACENT TO PRISONS OR STAY
HOSPITALS THAT ARE YOU KNOW
SAFELY AWAY BUT VERY AVAILABLE
AND WE HAVE TYPE URBAN SITES
LIKE THIS AS WELL -- SO NOW TO
RESOLVE TO TALK ABOUT THE
SCREENING CRITERIA.
HI AND SOCIAL SAKE I AM THE DATE
IN RESEARCH MANAGER FOR HOUSING
POLICY AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT.
AND WE'VE BEEN REALLY FORTUNATE
TO GET TO WORK WITH DTS IN A
REALLY GREAT PARTNERSHIP IN
SHORT TIMING -- TO GET THIS DONE
SO THE EXECUTIVE ORDER ASKED THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TO FOCUS
ON TWO COMPONENTS TO SCREENING
TOOLS HIGHLIGHTED ON THE SLIDES
AS HOUSING NEED.
AND ECONOMIC FEASIBILITY THE
TALK ABOUT THEM QUICKLY BUT TALK
ABOUT THE DATA THAT'S BEHIND
THEM.
I AND SO FOR HOUSING NEED REALLY
THERE WERE JUST TRYING TO SEE
WHERE HOUSING IS MOST NEEDED AND
MOST IMPACTFUL AS DESIGNED AND
AN IO.
SO WE LOOK AT AVAILABILITY OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
GAP BETWEEN SUPPLY AND DEMAND
AND THE RATE OF INCREASE IN RENT.
SO FOR THE AVAILABILITY OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
WE'RE LOOKING AT HOW MUCH
HOUSING IS AVAILABLE IN THE JOB
AND COMMUTERS SHEDS SPECIFICALLY
WHERE THE SHORTFALL OF VERY LOW
INCOME UNITS.
EXCEEDS 30% OF THE NEED SO WE'RE
REALLY TRYING TO GET AT FOR VERY
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS IS THERE
ENOUGH HOUSING.
THAT'S THE FIRST MEASURE THE
SECOND BEING THE GAP BETWEEN
SUPPLY AND DEMAND AND HERE WE
RELY ON SOME OF THE NUMBERS THAT
ARE.
PROJECTED AGAINST THE REGIONAL
HOUSING NEED ALLOCATION WHICH IS
A TOPIC THAT WOULD TAKE ANOTHER
PRESENTATION TO REALLY COVER BUT
JUST TO SAY THAT THERE ARE
PLANNING GOALS SET. FOR EACH
REGION AND FOR EACH CITY WITHIN
REGIONS AND SO WE LOOK AT WHERE
THE GAP BETWEEN THE REGIONAL
HOUSING NEED ALLOCATION.
AND THE BUILDING PERMITS ISSUED
IS GREATER THAN FIFTEEN HUNDRED
SO WHERE WE START SEEING THERE'S
NOT ENOUGH ACTIVITY ON THE
PRODUCTION SIDE.
AND THEN THIRD WHERE THE RATE OF
INCREASE IN RENT -- SPECIFICALLY
WHERE THE MEDIAN GROSS RENT
INCREASED BY MORE THAN 5%.
YEAR OVER YEAR FROM TWENTY
SIXTEEN TO TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND
DATA SOURCES FOR ALL OF THIS FOR
USING PUBLICLY AVAILABLE DATA.
SO FOR EXAMPLE USING JUST THOSE
THREE HOUSING NEED COMPONENTS
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO SHOWS THAT
IN EACH OF THOSE MATTERS.
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO NEEDS
HOUSING I KNOW THAT'S NOT
SURPRISING HERE BUT MARKING ON
EACH OF THOSE MEASURES THAT IS A
DEMONSTRATED NEED HERE SO THAT'S
ONE COMPONENT.
ON THE ECONOMIC FEASIBILITY THIS
REALLY BUILD OFF OF THE ANALYSIS
THAT CHASEN'S TEAM DID SO BEYOND
VISUAL SIDE IDENTIFICATION AS
FOR THINKING CAN'T ANYTHING
ACTUALLY GET BUILT THERE THAT'S
ONE COMPONENT OF ECONOMIC
FEASIBILITY.
FURTHER WE'RE LOOKING AT OTHER
MEASURES THAT MIGHT PROMOTE.
OR THAT MIGHT MAKE IT POSSIBLE
FOR A DEVELOPER TO SEEK OTHER
FORMS OF SUBSIDY OR FUNDING --
AND BY LOCATION OF THE PARCEL WE
KIND OF KNOW WHETHER OR NOT
THOSE SITES MAY BE COMPETITIVE.
AND SO FOR EXAMPLE WE LOOK AT
PROXIMITY TO JOB CENTERS.
AND THERE WERE THE NUMBER OF
WORKERS WITH LESS THAN A A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE -- FALL REALLY
HIGH -- AWAY FROM HOW MUCH THE
AVAILABILITY THERE IS -- AND SO
WE GO FURTHER INTO PROXIMITY TO
EDUCATION.
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT ARE THERE
SCHOOLS CLOSE BY.
ARE THERE GOOD SCHOOLS CLOSE BY
AND THERE WE USE SOME OF THE TAX
CREDIT ALLOCATION COMMITTEE AND
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITY MAPS TO
GET SOME OF THAT DATA.
AND THE SAME THING WITH THE
PROXIMITY TO HIGH FREQUENCY
PUBLIC TRANSIT.
SO NOT ONLY.
THE PROXIMITY OF A SITE WITHIN
THOSE THREE AREAS PROMOTE
FEASIBILITY BUT ALSO HELPS MAKE
SURE THAT THE AFFORDABILITY OF
THE HOUSING AND TRANSPORTATION
INDEX OR THAT THAT HOUSEHOLD MAY
PAY IN THEIR HOUSING AND
TRANSPORTATION COSTS.
MIGHT BE LESS IF THE PERSONAL IS
LOCATED IN THESE THREE AREAS.
SO THOSE ARE SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WE'RE CONSIDERING BUT THAT
IS TO SAY WERE ALSO EXPLORING
OTHER COMPONENTS OF ECONOMIC
FEASIBILITY AS WE GET DEEPER
INTO THE ANALYSIS -- WITH THE
CREATION OF THE OPPORTUNITIES
OWN PROGRAM FOR EXAMPLE WE'RE
NOT USING THAT IS PRESCRIPTIVE
BUT JUST ANOTHER CONSIDERATION
SIMILAR WHETHER OR NOT A PARCEL
IS AN AREA WHERE CLIMB
INVESTMENTS COULD BE LEVERAGED.
AND ALSO LOCAL SOURCES OF
FUNDING AND ESPECIALLY AS WE GET
INTO THAT LOCAL COORDINATION
WILL BE LOOKING AT THAT.
SO JUST OTHER DETERMINANTS OF
FEASIBILITY OR THINGS THAT WE
WILL BE CONTINUING TO EXPLORE --
AND ONE OTHER NOTE AS I
MENTIONED YOU KNOW WAS WE TALK
ABOUT HOUSING NEED WE JUST
RECENTLY ISSUED OUR
DETERMINATION OF WHERE
JURISDICTIONS ARE AT IN MEETING
THE REGIONAL HOUSING NEED
ALLOCATION.
AND IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY AND
EIGHTEEN CITIES WITHIN THE
COUNTY ONLY 10% OF JURISDICTIONS
ARE ON PACE TO MEET ALL OF THE
REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ALLOCATION.
AND THAT'S IF WE TOOK THEIR
PROGRESS IN THEIR PLANNING
PERIOD TODAY SO IT'S A VERY
SMALL NUMBER AND CONSIDERING
THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT EIGHTEEN
JURISDICTIONS. 10% IS NOT A
REALLY COMPELLING NUMBER HERE
YOU KNOW SO WE STILL HAVE A LONG
WAY TO GO.
THIS IS NOT ONLY IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY THIS IS A STATE WIDE
ISSUE I AM SO THE STATE OF
FACTORS ARE REPRESENTATIVE OF
THE TYPES OF THINGS THAT WE'RE
SEEING OR TRYING.
TO FOCUS OUR ATTENTION IN THOSE
HIGH NEED AREAS [INAUDIBLE]
SO [INAUDIBLE] TO THE THANK YOU.
ART SO WHERE WE GO FROM HERE SO --
ARE DEVELOPMENT APPROACHES IS
PRETTY SIMPLE -- THESE WOULD BE
STATE DEVELOPMENT SO WE'RE NOT
PLANNING UNNECESSARILY ON
CONCERT BLESSING PROPERTY ALL
THAT THAT MAY HAPPEN TIME TO
TIME IN THERE ARE NUMBER OF
SURPLUS PROPERTIES ON OUR LIST
AS WELL -- THEY WOULD BE STATE
DEVELOPMENTS MEANING LONG TERM
GROUND LEASES TO PRIVATE
DEVELOPERS -- WE WOULD LEVERAGE
STATE PROPERTY VALUES FREE --
ARE NOT HOLD ME LOOKING TO MAKE
RETURNS ON THESE DEVELOPMENTS
AND SO -- HAPPY TO TO TO MAKE
THOSE VERY VERY LOW AND VERY
LONG TERM GROUND LEASES -- AND
THEN WE DO WANT TO FOCUS ON
INNOVATIVE CONSTRUCTION
TECHNIQUES -- WHETHER THAT
SMUGGLER PREFAB CLT MICRO UNITS --
WHATEVER WE CAN DO OLD EMILY --
TO TO DRIVE NOT JUST INNOVATION
THE SPEAR BUT ALSO MAKE THESE TO
BUBBLE FASTER QUICKER -- AND
CHEAPER -- WITH LIKEWISE LOOK
MAKING SURE THAT THESE ARE NONE
THE LESS ATTAINABLE DEVELOPMENTS --
AND EQUITABLE TO THERE'S A FOCUS
ON PREVAILING WAGE AND AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT IN THE
EXECUTIVE ORDERS WELL.
AND THEN JUST A COUPLE OTHER
HIGHLIGHTS -- I THINK ARE
RELEVANT EXECUTIVE ORDER DOES
CALL OUT -- LAND SWAPS AS
POSSIBILITIES I MENTIONED THERE
WERE A COUPLE OF LOCAL ENTITIES
THAT HAVE APPROACHED US -- ABOUT --
CO DEVELOPMENTS AS WELL WE ARE
MORE THAN HAPPY AND WE'VE WE'VE
EXPRESS THIS WITH YOU KNOW HALF
A DOZEN -- LOCALITIES ACROSS THE
STATE TO LOOK AT INNOVATIVE WAYS
OF DEVELOPING MAYBE OUR
PROPERTIES -- AREN'T GREAT --
BUT THERE'S NOT A LAND SWAP DEAL --
WE COULD WE COULD COMBINE
DEVELOPMENTS -- MAYBE IT'S MORE
OF A SALE MAYBE IT'S A SALE --
IN THE PROCEEDS GO TO OFFSET OR
EVEN AFFORDABILITY SOMEWHERE
ELSE MEAN WHERE WE REALLY WANT
TO MAKE SURE IT WORKS FINE ALL
OPTIONS -- AND NOT LOOKING AT A
SINGLE WAY OF APPROACHING THE
SITES -- I DID MENTION ALL
LEVERAGING STING SURPLUS
PROPERTY -- ONE OF THE
INTERESTING THINGS EXCITING
THINGS ABOUT THE EXECUTIVE ORDER
IS THAT THERE HAVE BEEN A NUMBER
OF SITES SOME PRETTY.
INTERESTING SITES OF THE STATE
HAS HAD FOR YEARS PAYING ONE
SHUT DOWN COST OF THIS EXECUTIVE
ORDER HAS SHAKEN LOOSE AND SO
THERE ARE A FEW SITES THAT WERE
IN BEGIN WORKING ON IN A WAY
THAT -- WE HADN'T BEEN ABLE TO
IN THE LAST DECADE OR SO -- AND
LASTLY THERE IS -- SOME MENTION
EXECUTIVE ORDER BUT POTENTIALLY
PRIORITIZE FUNDING AS WELL
THAT'S NOT -- DEFINED OR
FINALIZE THIS POINT BUT WE ARE
LOOKING AND CAN'T OF EXPECTING
TO BE ABLE -- TO TO REALLY DIG
INTO THE SITES AND DO SOME NEXT
BUT EITHER WAY IN THE NEXT
COUPLE OF MONTHS.
ALL RIGHT ANY -- WITH THAT I
THINK WE'RE DONE ANY ANY
QUESTIONS I'M SURE THERE ARE
TIMES.
WHEN FIRST CASES SUCH THANK YOU
FOR THE PREACHER TATIAN?
I SHOULD SAY OUT THE BAD.
I WAS OVERJOYED WHEN GOVERNOR
SOME PRACTICE EXECUTIVE ORDER --
I THINK FOR A GOVERNOR WHO AND
EXPRESSLY CO HOUSING PLATFORM IT
WAS REFRESHING NOT JUST TO SEE
THIS GUY CAN WATER GO OUT BUT TO
GO OUT SO EARLY IN HIS
ADMINISTRATION I THINK STATE A
TEMPO.
THE STATE'S COUNTRY A TRUE
LEADER ON THIS ANYBODY BUT THOSE
OF US FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT WHO
OFTEN FEEL AS OF THE STATE I
KNOW IS TO BE ANY STUFF OF US --
THIS IS A I THINK SYMBOLIC THAT
THE STATE IS WILLING TO WALK
IT'S ONE O'CLOCK RIGHT -- THAT
THEY'RE GONNA BE PART TO
PARTNERS OF PARTICIPANTS IN
TRYING TO SOLVE THIS CRISIS SO
CERTAINLY KUDOS TO GOVERNOR
NEEDS SOME -- FOR NOT ONLY
IDENTIFYING THIS AS FOR WHAT IT
IS WHICH IS THE BIGGEST PROBLEM
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
BUT FOR ACTUALLY LEADING ON ON
THAT AREA WE HAVE SOME MORE
CONTROLLED BY BECAUSE WE ON THE
PROPERTY -- AND I WOULD DEFY
ANYONE TO LOOK AT THIS
PRESENTATION AND OUTCOME AWAIT
THE REALLY IMPRESSED BY WHAT YOU
ALL PUT TOGETHER IN A RELATIVELY
SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME -- YEAH
THIS IS A FEW MONTHS TO BE
ADMINISTRATION RIGHT SIX MONTHS
BARELY MAYBE THERE ABOUT --
AGAIN I THINK IT'S EXTREMELY
THOUGHTFUL ME BOTH IN TERMS OF
THE SCOPE OF THE EXECUTIVE ORDER
AS WELL AS THE TOOLS AND THE THE
FILTERS THAT YOU PUT THIS
THROUGH.
YEAH AND AND NOT A BRIEF AMOUNT
OF TIME IT TOOK TO SCALE THE FOR
THE FOLKS ARE TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND I THINK I HEARD YOU
MAKE MENTION JJ'S AND THAT.
IN AN AVERAGE YEAR YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT ONE TO FOUR
PROPERTIES MAYBE IN A YEAR.
DO THIS EXECUTIVE ORDER YOU'RE
CURRENTLY LOOKING AT ABOUT A
HUNDRED SITES IS THAT RIGHT.
I MEAN SAID IT'S A PICTURE OF
THE SCALE OF WHAT CAN BE DONE
HERE RELATIVE TO OUR HISTORIC
PERFORMANCE WHICH I THINK IS IN
KEEPING WITH THE SIZE THE CRISIS
IN THE BEAUTY OF LIFE.
CALIFORNIANS ARE DEALING WITH
SOME I I THINK THAT'S FANTASTIC --
THE THERE WERE A NUMBER.
I GET TO THIS HOUSE WHERE --
THREE EIGHT TERMS THE
IMPLEMENTATION STEPS I BELIEVE
YOU'RE AT THE MIDDLE OF IT RIGHT
BESIDE PRIVATIZATION.
YEAH AND ALL OF THIS -- TO GET
THROUGH ALL THAT [INAUDIBLE]
COUNTING.
SEVEN ALL SEVEN STEPS BY THE END
OF SEPTEMBER IS THAT YEAH NOT
NOT OLD SITES WILL BE DEVELOPED
AT THE SAME TIME -- OBVIOUSLY
THE AND THERE'S THERE'S ONLY SO
MANY RESOURCES THAT WE HAD TO
ISSUE THESE ARE PEAS AND WE
DON'T ALSO SATURATE THE MARKET --
THE INITIAL OUR PEACE NEED TO GO
OUT BUT IN SEPTEMBER -- WE
IMAGINE THIS TO BE SOMETHING
THAT TIME -- MOST OF THE SITES
WE DO HAVE -- THEY'RE NOT
ENCUMBERED PERMANENTLY BUT THEY
DO HAVE SOME SHORT TERM
ENCUMBRANCES -- AND SO -- LIKE
FOR EXAMPLE YOU KNOW TO BE
ASSEMBLY BUILDINGS -- THAT YOU
JUST YOU KNOW MODOC ADVISE ON
THE ON THE LIST -- AND SO.
THEY'LL TAKE AWHILE TO GET THE
GET THOSE GUYS OUT INTO -- THE
LEAST MARKET ALTER LOCATIONS AND
SO YES I DAY IN THERE AND THEY
WILL BE A SENSE OF A PROGRESSION
IN THIS.
BUT YES OUR OUR FIRST TO GO FROM
ASIANS EXECUTIVE ORDER TO OUR
FIRST ART PIECE OUT AND
ESSENTIALLY IN A FEW MONTHS OR
SO IS.
IT'S BEEN LEFT.
BUT IT I MEAN IT'S REMARKABLE
WHAT YOU'VE DONE TO ME STARTED
FORTY FOUR THOUSAND PARCELS THAT
YOU.
SURVEYED MANY GET TO WHERE YOU
ARE NOW IN THE SHORT ON TIME
AGAIN THE MARKET WILL KUDOS.
TONS OF APPRECIATION -- IN TERMS
THE ISSUES THAT ARE OF PEAS WE
SAY THERE'S NO PROMISES OF THE
NUMBER OF OUR FEES THAT COME OUT --
HE'S EVEN CURRENTLY AT ROUGHLY A
HUNDRED ASSUMING THAT YOU KNOW
SPELL OUT FORTY OF THE REASONS
THAT YOU MENTIONED -- WHAT WE
SHOULD EXPECT AND -- HUNDRED
ALRIGHT PEAS -- IN SEPTEMBER --
IT'S GONNA BE SOMETHING YEAH
IT'LL BE LESS THAN A HUNDRED I
MEAN I I PROBABLY I HONESTLY I
WOULD IMAGINE PROBABLY THE FIRST
ROUND WILL BE BETWEEN THEM YOU
KNOW.
THREE ASH -- WOULD BE PLAY THE
PROBABLY THE THE THAN INITIALS
ALTHOUGH -- AND THEN WILL TEST
THE WATERS AS WELL -- WE'RE NOT
ENTIRELY SURE -- EXACTLY HOW
MANY RESPONSES WERE GOING TO GET
THE THE FIRST LITTLE BIT TO SEE
HOW IT GOES IN THE KIND OF WORK
OVER EXPERIENCING.
ISSUES RUN INTO WE MIGHT HAVE TO
RETOOL OUR P. WITH MY THREE TO
OUR GROUND THESE ALL THAT WE'RE
GOING TO WANT TO NOT GET TOO FAR
AHEAD OF OURSELVES AND JUST PULL
BACK CONSIDERABLY.
I DIDN'T OBVIOUSLY THERE'S
ALWAYS THE RISK OF DOING
SOMETHING WRONG SO YOU DON'T
WANT TO PUT ON EVERYTHING ALL AT
ONCE EXACTLY SO IF YOU ISSUE
YOUR FIRST ART P. SOMETIME IN
THE FALL WHEN WITH THE NEXT
GROUP OF OUR PEACE GO OUT ANY
ADULT.
YEAH THAT'S A THAT'S A TASK OF
THOSE SELF MANAGING A
COMPETITIVE PROCESS HE'LL BE IS
THERE THE BAND WITH TO BE ABLE
TO CONTINUE WORKING ON THE
REMAINING. NINETY SEVEN CARS.
OPPORTUNITIES IS IT WHAT'S
WHAT'S THE CONTINUAL PUSH TO
MAKE SURE THAT THESE THESE
PROPERTIES ARE BEING RELEASED IN.
AND PUT OUT OF FOR FOR INTEREST
SO I HAVE -- YEAH THE WHOLE
UNITS WHOSE DEDICATED PURPOSE IS
THE DISPOSITION STATE PROPERTY --
INCLUDING LONG TERM DEVELOPMENTS --
IT'S NOT A HUGE UNIT LIKE I SAID
YOU KNOW FOR PROPERTIES YEAR
PLUS OR MINUS -- MOST OF THE
DEALS THEY WORK ON OUR IN THE
CONTEXT MUCH WORK OF THIS IS
THAT'S GOING TO BE IF YOU KNOW
OVERLY ONEROUS WE MIGHT ASK
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES -- BUT I
THINK ULTIMATELY -- WE'RE STILL
KIND OF TRYING TO FIGURE THAT
OUT YOU DISPLAY WHERE IT'S GOING
WITH THIS MAKING SURE THAT YOUR
RESOURCE TO BE ABLE TO DO.
THIS WORK I MEAN IT'S A POOR TO
GET THESE WERE PROPERTIES
RELEASE BUT NO ONE WANTS TO DO A
TAXPAYER GIVEAWAY -- SO -- IT'S
A IT'S A DELICATE BALANCE BUT IF
PASSAGE PROLONG YOUR YOUR OB YOU
GOING ON IS A VERY SMART FASHION.
I WOULD SUSPECT THAT YOU WILL
LET US KNOW -- IT'S A
MINISTRATION BUT THOSE ARE
LEGISLATURE WHO WANT TO BE
SUPPORTED GOING TO THE SCREEN
TOOL IF I MAY UM.
SUCH I BELIEVE YOU MENTIONED
THAT THE THE FIRST BULLET
HOUSING NEED THAT THE FOUR OF
THE AVAILABILITY OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IS MEASURED BY VERY LOW
INCOME HOUSING AND DID I
UNDERSTAND YOU CORRECTLY.
YES FOR EARLY BECAUSE OF THEIR
AS OPPOSED TO LOW INCOME OR
MODERATE INCOME HOUSING.
OKAY AND IT'S NOT TO SAY THERE'S
NOT STILL A GAP THERE BUT WE'RE
REALLY JUST FIRST PURPOSES OF
MEASURING AND HAVING A
CONSISTENT MEASUREMENT KNOWING
THAT IT FOR NOT MEETING THE MOST
VERY LOW INCOME.
OR SEEN TRICKLE OF FACTS AND ALL
THE OTHER INCOME CATEGORIES
GENERALLY FROM A LOOK AT THE
DATA IN RECOGNIZING OF BACK TO
THE LATTER YOU KNOW THAT THERE'S
MANY OF THOSE RATHER DOES NOT
EXIST AND IF.
HAVE BEST MAYBE REALLY FRAIL --
SO YOU'RE USING THE METRIC OF
VERY LOW WHICH HAS A DEFINITION
AS THE LATTER INDICATE -- AND
THEN YOUR ANSWER WAS UP THESE
THREE SCREENS ROUSING THE CITY
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO ACTUALLY
QUALIFIES.
AND I THINK YOU FOR THE MENTION
THAT OF EIGHTEEN CITIES -- IN
THE IN THE COUNTY IT SOUNDS LIKE
ONE OR TWO BABY.
ON BASE.
PACE NOT WHICH IS DIFFERENT THAN
AND THEN MISSION ACCOMPLISHED
TRIED TO RIGHTLY CLEAR POINT AND
FIND OUT THE STATUS OF WOMEN
GROW BY THINK THEY MIGHT BE THE
ONE YEAH I AM I BELIEVE THAT IT
IS LIMÓN GROW -- BUT I HAVE
OTHER STATISTICS TO TO SHOW JUST
PERCENTAGES WITHIN THE COUNTY
BUT I HAD IT'S ALSO NOT GOOD --
ONLY 84% OF JURISDICTIONS ARE
MEETING THEIR VERY LOW FOR ARE
ON PACE TO ME THEY'RE VERY LOW
AND LOW TARGETS -- 90% ARE NOT
MEETING THEIR MODERATE TARGETS --
AND THIRTY TWO ARE NOT MEETING
THEIR ABOVE
MODERATE TARGETS SO
MOST AND THIS IS DIFFICULT TO
WHAT WE SEE THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
IT IS EASIER GENERALLY EASIER TO
BUILD AND FOR RESTRICTIONS ARE
PRIORITIZING ABOVE MARK ABOVE
MODERATE.
DEVELOPMENT FOR MARKET
DEVELOPMENT RIGHT RIGHT TO THE
HARD TO BUILD AND EVEN THE
MIDDLE TO BUILD COAXING AND I
THINK THE GOVERNOR HAS MADE
CLEAR THAT HE'S INTENDED TO DO --
BOTH CARROTS AND STICKS TO TO
HELP ADDRESS THIS CRISIS CAN I
JUST ADD ONE THING TO JUST THIS
THE SCREEN CRITERIA CERTAINLY
FOCUSING ON LOW INCOME BUT IT
DOESN'T MEAN NECESSARILY THAT --
YOU KNOW ALL OF OUR ADULT MUCH
REALLY FOCUSED THAT WAY EITHER --
IT IS A GOOD CLARIFICATION WE
HAVE FOR EXAMPLE -- ONE
POTENTIAL DEVELOPMENT DEAL -- IN
SAN JOSE WHICH WILL BE.
THE FOCUS OF THE MIDDLE INCOME
FOR EXAMPLE.
SEE YOU IN MY HEAD JASON BECAUSE
I WANT TO MAKE SURE I MEAN
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE AT THE COMMITTEE
FOR WORKING MIDDLE CLASS HOUSING
RIGHT AND YOU KNOW.
THAT WHILE THERE IS TREMENDOUS
NEED I THINK THERE'S A LOWE'S
GONNA FOLKS SHOW US SHORTLY NAY
YEAH WE ARE HAPPY TO HAVE
PRODUCTION AND VERY LOW LOW
INCOME WITH NEXT TO NOTHING IN
THE MIDDLE.
AND MY HOPE WOULD BE THAT THE
STATE'S LEAN IN ON THIS -- YEAH
I WILL CONCERNS ABOUT THE
VIABILITY OF THE MIDDLE CLASS IN
CALIFORNIA -- YEAH IN THE
GOVERNOR IS CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
AS WELL AND IF WE'RE GONNA BE
DOING SOMETHING ABOUT THIS.
THESE PROPERTIES ARE ASSETS THAT
CAN ACCRUE TO THE BENEFIT OF
WORKING MIDDLE CLASS PEOPLE
FOLKS GET EVERY SINGLE DAY GO TO
A JOB PAY THEIR TAXES PLAY BY
THE RULES -- THEY NEED TO SEE
THE STATE SEES THAT HERE'S THAT
IS DOING SOMETHING FOR THEM --
AND I HOPE THAT THIS EXERCISE
WOULD BE A PART OF THAT AFTER AT
THE RISK OF GETTING MYSELF IN
TROUBLE -- YEAH THERE THERE'S A
NUMBER OF STATE INSTITUTIONS
ACROSS THE STATE -- YOU KNOW
HOSPITALS VETERAN CENTERS YOU
KNOW IN YOUR BILL AND NAPA AND
WE'VE GOT PRISONS IN FOLSOM AND
AND YOU KNOW THERE'S PLACES
WHERE -- PEOPLE ARE HAVING TO
COMMUTE LONG DISTANCES JUST TO
GO TO WORK AT THE STATE
FACILITIES AND SO -- YOU KNOW A
POSSIBILITY OF DOING SOMETHING
THAT'S WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AS
WELL OR HOUSING FOCUSED AS WELL
ADDING IS IS YOU KNOW THE WHOLE
TABLE FOR US YEAH.
I LIKE THAT ANSWER.
AND SO ONE COMPONENT TO I THINK
IS THAT WITH THE WE'LL SEE IN
THE FIRST ROUND OF ART PEAS AND
WE REALLY WOULD HAVE WANTED TO
LEAVE SPACE CREATIVITY FOR
DEVELOPERS AND FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. TO COME TO THE TABLE
AND THINK ABOUT WHAT SOLUTIONS
MAKE SENSE AND SO I THINK THAT
IS ALSO WHAT WILL BE LEARNING IN
THE FIRST ROUND AND CONTINUE
GROUNDS IS WHAT CREATIVITY WE
ARE.
NOT YOU KNOW THAT THE ONLY ONES
WITH GOOD IDEAS HERE AND WE
WELCOME LOCAL SOLUTIONS ON TO
COME UP WITH WHAT MAKES SENSE.
I LOVE THAT I JUST TRY TO WRAP
BUT THE LEVEL ON THE EDITOR.
ECONOMIC FEASIBILITY FOR YOUR
SCREENING TOOLS ARE SENATE HIGH
FREQUENCY PUBLIC TRANSIT HOW ARE
YOU DEFINING HIGH FREQUENCY.
OF ITS ANY AREA WITHIN THE STATE
THE TEN WITH AND HAVE A WE'RE
CONSIDERING WOULD BE THERE BUT
WE KNOW THAT THAT'S A WAY TO
PROMOTE ECONOMIC FEASIBILITY.
NOT ONLY FOR THE DEVELOPER
BEFORE THE HOUSEHOLDS.
WHAT ARE YOU MAKING THAT WAS
PARTY TESTIMONY WHICH IS SPOT ON
I'VE GOT DEFINITION IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT SENATOR WE DON'T I CAN
SPEND A LOT OF TIME GOING BACK
AND FORTH?
WHAT IS THE DEFINITION OF HIGH
FREQUENCY PUBLIC TRANSIT -- I
THINK QUIRK A QUARTER MILE IN
FIFTEEN MINUTE HEADWAYS.
ABSOLUTELY QUALIFY THEY GOING
BEYOND THAT WE START TO REALLY
STRETCH AND WE PROBABLY DO NEED
TO STRETCH THE THE SENATE THE
SIZE AND SCALE OF CLIMATE CRISIS
IS SO SIGNIFICANT WE PROBABLY
NEED TO DO THAT.
HOWEVER I THINK FOR THE LIVED
EXPERIENCE OF THE PEOPLE WERE
TRYING TO HOUSE THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS A QUARTER MILE AND AND
SEVEN MINUTE FIFTEEN MINUTE.
LOOK AT SHARON AND PAUL WHO I
KNOW THAT A CHEAP TO DO THAT
LOVED EVERY LEVEL OF FREQUENCY
BUT THESE THINGS ARE ALL
CONNECTED WHICH IS PRECISELY WHY
WE HAVE CLIMB AS OUR LAST.
DISCUSSION THE LAST ROUND OF
QUESTIONS IS SHAMELESS PROMOTION
I THINK YOU MAY BE AWARE OF
DOING ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN SIXTY
FOUR AROUND THE STATE BUILDING
HERE IN SAN DIEGO -- CAN YOU
COMMENT ON THAT IS IN THE
LEGISLATION THAT'S NOT THAT'S
NOT YOUR THAT'S FOR OTHER PEOPLE
TO DO -- BUT CAN YOU -- LET US
KNOW WHERE THAT PROPERTY MAY BE
IN TERMS OF THE SCREEN AND THE
RPM HAD TO PROCESS.
YEAH I MEAN THAT -- IT'S IT'S A
IT'S A INTERESTING SITE AND
THAT'S NOT JUST A STATE OFFICE
BUILDING BUT THERE'S ALSO A LOT
ACROSS THE STREET WITH A
CONDEMNED BUILDING AND THE OTHER --
ONE AND IT'S IT'S LITERALLY
FLANKED ON ALL SIDES BY. THIRTY
STORY HIGH RISE BUILDINGS -- BUT
YES THAT WE DO WE ARE
ANTICIPATING THAT BUILDING BEING
ON OUR ACCESS LIST.
LIKE THAT THE ANSWER.
YOU CAN IMAGINE -- THE THAT
ANGST I HAVE I KNOW WE'RE TRYING
TO PUSH LOCALITIES TO DO THAT WE
HAVE TO PULL CITY BLOCKS --
THERE'S OWN FOR HIGH DENSITY
HOUSING -- WITH ONE SIX STORY
BUILDING THAT IS SEEN FAR BETTER
DAYS AND AS YOU MENTION A
CONDEMNED BUILDING ON THE OTHER
ONE DOESN'T SPEAK WELL FOR THE
FOR THE STATE -- HOW TO SHARE
GETTING TOTALLY UP FOR
NEIGHBORHOOD LEVEL THESE ARE
AREAS IS OUR BOX FOR A LOT OF
FUN COMMUNITY COMPLAINT -- IN
TERMS OF ILLEGAL LODGING --
SMELL AND GARBAGE OTHER KINDS OF
ISSUES -- TGS STAFF FOR DOING
THE VERY BEST THEY CAN TO
MITIGATE THAT BUT ULTIMATELY THE
BLIGHTED CONDITION THEY ARE ONLY
TRACKS MORE DEUCES.
AND THE FACT THAT YOU COULD DO A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT HOUSING THERE --
THIS IS IS THE IMPETUS THE
DESIRED AND THEY'VE GOT -- SO WE
BILL -- ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR
INTRODUCED I'M NOT SURE WHERE
THAT I'M GLAD IT'S ON THE RADAR.
THERE WAS A REPORT WE PUBLISHED
JUST A FEW MONTHS BACK -- THAT
THAT THE INDICATE WHICH
BUILDINGS ACROSS OF A POLIO
STATEWIDE THAT WE WOULD BE
DECLARING XSLT LONG TERM LOOKING --
TO DISPOSITION -- THAT BUILDING
AND THAT BOTH THOSE LAWS ARE
DEFINITELY ON IT -- AND WE'RE
WE'RE HAPPY IN THE CONVERSATION
ABOUT YOU KNOW WHAT'S WHAT'S THE
MOST APPROPRIATE THOSE LAWS -- I
GOT ALL KINDS IDEAS -- QUICKLY
GET SHE WAS PROMOTION -- THE
EASY EIGHT HOTEL WHICH IS
CURRENTLY -- INTERESTED IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION --
IN OLD TOWN EMILY JASON BELLTOWN
TRANSIT CENTER I DID LEGISLATION
TO ALLOW THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO
TO UTILIZE THAT PROPERTY IF IT
IF IT DESIRED -- TO I THINK
WHATEVER WE CAN DO TO TO
EXTINGUISH THE LEAST THERE AND
HAVE IT IS A NEW LIFE WE'RE
HAVING TREMENDOUS SUCCESS
HOUSING HOMELESS PEOPLE IN FOR
THE MOTEL FACILITIES I THINK
THIS IS A NO BRAINER.
IT'S NEAR OUR COUNTY HEALTH CARE
SERVICES I MEAN IT'S JUST
THERE'S A LOT OF WAYS WHERE
AGAIN LIKE THE STATE'S DOING ALL
IT CAN TO BE A SOLUTION PROVIDER --
THE SOON TO BE VACATED SEAT
FACILITY ABOUT A BLOCK AWAY ON
PACIFIC HIGHWAY -- IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY A RESIDENTIAL AREA
BUT THAT MIGHT.
ALLOW FOR USES THAT OTHER
RESIDENTS NEIGHBORHOODS MAY NOT
WANT -- AGAIN THAT'S A
POSSIBILITY IN MY LAST AND I'M
THAT THIS ISN'T ACTUALLY
QUESTION -- THE DMV IN HILLCREST --
IS CURRENTLY SLATED FOR A
REPLACEMENT -- SENATOR ATKINS
AND I HAVE BEEN THERE VOCAL AND
NOT WANTING TO SEE THE STANDARD
ISSUE SUBURBAN DMV ON THAT URBAN
INFILL SITE NOT A STRAIGHT
TALKING ABOUT YEAH AND THE STAFF
HAS BEEN VERY RESPONSIVE AND PUT
THE PROPOSED PROJECT ON ICE.
THIS WOULD NOT BE ACCESS BECAUSE
THE STATE STILL HAS A USE OF
FORCE THAT WOULD REALLY BE PART
OF YOUR PRESENTATION.
TODAY BUT I'M HOPEFUL THAT
WHATEVER COMES BACK FROM THAT
SORT OF INTERNAL PROCESSES ONE
IS A MIXED USE.
PROPERTY WITH A FULL SCALE DMV
BUT WITH A BOATLOAD WORKFORCE
HOUSING ON TOP OF IT -- WE AS A
COMMUNITY AS A STATE MR BLONSKY
IS RUNNING HIGH FREQUENCY PUBLIC
TRANSIT A BLOCK AWAY -- THIS IS
A COMMUNITY THAT'S CURRENTLY
RENT YOU KNOW IN IN THIRTY MORE
INFILL -- SEVERAL STORY
BUILDINGS THERE THE COMMUNITY IS
ACCEPTING OF THIS WHICH GOOD
LUCK FINDING THAT A LOT OF
PLACES -- SO IT JUST SEEMS TO ME
THIS IS A NO BRAINER I'M REALLY
HOPEFUL IN THE CONTEXT OF
EXECUTIVE ORDER TO GET THIS
PROPERTY IS A FALL INTO THAT
FILTER -- BUT I THINK IT COULD
BE ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF THE STATE
OF THE STATE -- WITH THESE HOW
THE RESPONSIBILITIES AND
CERTAINLY A WAY TO KEEP FAITH
WITH WORKING A MIDDLE CLASS
CALIFORNIANS ARE LOOKING FOR A
PLACE TO LIVE -- IF I CAN JUST
REPEAT IT NOW TO BE A DEAD HORSE
INCREDIBLE WORK REALLY ABLE TO
EXCEPTIONAL WORKING PLEASE LET
ME KNOW HOW WE CAN BEST SUPPORT
YOU IN CONSERVING TO PURSUE THIS.
HUNDRED PROPERTIES I THINK WOULD
NOT CLEARLY YOU'LL THOUSAND
HOMES FOR CALIFORNIANS ONLY BE
SUPPORT AS POSSIBLE WHICH AFTER.
AFTER THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU GUYS VERY MUCH.
WE'LL GO TO ASK THE BIG CHEESE
HIMSELF -- POGGIBONSI OUR CEO
THE CITY OF THE DEPOSIT TRANSIT
SYSTEM I HAVE A GREAT DEEP LOVE
FOR POSSIBLE ON SKI AND I
APPRECIATE THAT HE'S HERE TODAY
BECAUSE WHAT THE STATE'S
EMBARKING ON THIS EFFORT.
HIS ORGANIZATION HAS BEEN
LOOKING AT ITS OWN PROPERTIES
FOR SOMETIME NOW WITH SOME GOOD
NEWS REPORT RIGHT SO OFTEN FOR
YOURS.
O'DONNELL I DON'T SHARE COULD
I'M THE PRESIDENT AND CLOUT
HOWEVER COME UP.
TO JUST TURN YOUR MICROPHONE
RIGHT [INAUDIBLE]
SPEAK.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH GREAT TO
SEE YOU.
I LOVE HEARING YOU TALK ABOUT
TRANSIT SO MUCH.
AND AND I KNOW EXACTLY WHERE YOU
GOT ALL THAT TRAINING SO THAT
MAKES ME VERY PROP 1100% YOU.
ANYWAY IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE
HERE AND YEAH WE HAVE A LOT OF
EXCITING THINGS GOING ON WITH
THE DEVELOPMENT OF HOUSING --
YOU KNOW WITHIN THE SYSTEM.
YOU KNOW JUST AS AN OPENING --
YOU KNOW T. O. D. HAS SPECIAL
MEANING TO US AND AND WE'VE
ALREADY LOOKING FOR WAYS AS WE
DEVELOP OUR PROPERTY OVER
WHETHER IT'S PARK AND RIDE SITES
OR OTHER SURPLUS PROPERTY.
TRANSIT ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT IS
GOING BUT ONLY IF IT GENERATES
WRITERS TO TRANSIT.
AND AND I THINK WHAT WE'VE SEEN
IN SOME OF OUR DEVELOPMENTS IN A
BIT MARKET RATE HOUSING -- WE
DON'T GET AS MUCH AS WE WOULD
HOPE TO YOU KNOW WE CAN WE HAVE
DEVELOPMENTS ALONG MISSION
VALLEY AND PLACES LIKE THAT THAT
YOU WOULD THINK GENERATE A LOT.
BUT PEOPLE WORKING SORRENTO AND
OTHERS AND AND THEY DON'T REALLY
ACCESS IT SO I THINK THIS VENUE
OR THIS VENTURE INTO MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
ESPECIALLY -- WORK FOR HOUSING
HOPEFULLY THAT LENDS ITSELF TO A
GREATER USE OF TRANSIT AND I
THINK YOU'RE GONNA SEE EVEN SOME
GREATER INITIATIVES ON OUR PART
TO INDUCE THAT AS WE GO FORWARD.
ANYWAY -- INVENTORY OF MTS
PROPERTY WE HAVE PROBABLY AT
LEAST SEVENTY ACRES THAT -- THAT
ARE AVAILABLE -- THAT'S GROSS
ACRES -- MANY OF THESE PLACES
HAVE -- TRANSIT USES ON ANYWHERE
FROM PARKING LOTS TO TRAIN
STATIONS TRACTION POWER
SUBSTATIONS -- IN OTHERS THAT WE
HAVE TO RETAIN FOR TRANSIT AND
EVEN SOME OF THE PARKING WERE WE
WE HAVE TO RETAIN ALTHOUGH.
A WE'RE TRYING TO MINIMIZE SAID
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE TO INCREASE
AND ELEMENT.
OTHER AREAS -- YOU KNOW WE HAVE
TO KEEP THAT HAVE A TRANSIT
CENTER ON A PER SE -- BUT OTHER
AREAS IN -- COMMUNITY PLANS FOR
EXAMPLE THE GRANT BILL
DEVELOPMENT THE WORKING ON NOW
HAS THE ELDORADO CREEK RIGHT
NEXT TO IT AND SO -- F. AS
YOU'LL SEE IN A SECOND A COUPLE
OF ACRES OF THAT PROPERTY WILL
ACTUALLY GO TO WORD -- CREEK
DEVELOPMENT -- THIS IS KIND OF
OUR INVENTORY RIGHT NOW AND
WE'VE GOT IT ALL OVER OUR SYSTEM
HE'S COUNTY WE'VE GOT -- FIVE
DIFFERENT LOCATIONS YEARS
USUALLY -- CHULA VISTA THREE
DIFFERENT LOCATIONS -- GENERALLY
OVER PARKING RIGHT SHOTS SITES
WHERE WE MAINTAIN PARKING THEN
BUILD OVER ON PODIUM -- CITY OF
SAN DIEGO HAS -- I THINK THERE'S
EIGHT SITES HERE ALL THE WAY
FROM RANCHO BERNARDO ALL THE WAY
DOWN -- TO BUYER AND THERE'S
SOME GREAT OPPORTUNITIES THERE --
AS YOU SEE THE ONES IN RED A RED
BECAUSE THOSE ARE THE ONES I'M
GOING TO FOCUS ON FOR TODAY'S
HEARING BECAUSE WE'RE PRETTY
ACTIVELY IN THE MIDDLE OF THOSE
RIGHT NOW AND SO I CAN GIVE A
GOOD TESTIMONY AS TO WHAT.
THEY ARE.
OF OUR POLICY EIGHTEEN IS THE
POLICY THAT HAS -- KIND OF
DIRECTED -- TRANSIT ORIENTED
DEVELOPMENT IN DEVELOPMENT ON
OUR PROPERTY.
AND WE RECENTLY MADE SOME
CHANGES TO IT OVERALL THE POLICY
PROVIDES DIRECTION TO STAFF ON
HOW BEST TO USE.
UTILIZE -- MTS PROPERTY -- WE
RECENTLY AMENDED IT TO
INCORPORATED AFFORDABLE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING COMPONENT IN
ALL OUR RESIDENTIAL SO THERE'S A
20% SET ASIDE NOW -- FOR
AFFORDABLE AND IT'S YOU KNOW I
THINK THE BOARD HOPES THAT THAT
WOULD BE IN THE VERY LOW AND LOW
INCOME AFFORDABILITY -- AND AS I
SAID IN THE BEGINNING AT THE
EXPECTATION IS THAT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE UNITS
AND AND PUTTING THAT FORD.
I HELPS WITH -- TRANSIT
RIDERSHIP AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
WE WOULD REALLY LIKE TO SEE --
ALSO AS PART OF THIS -- POLICY
IN IN OUR PROCUREMENT POLICY
POLICY FIFTY TWO IS DIRECTLY
RELATED TO THIS.
THE BOARD AT ITS NEXT MEETING
WILL ENTERTAIN REQUIRING OF
PREVAILING WAGE -- IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF OF PROJECTS ON
OUR ACCESS PROPERTY -- STORE
ALREADY DEVELOPING SOME OF
PROJECTS UNDER THIS NEW POLICY --
THE FIRST ONE THAT I'D LIKE TO
TALK ABOUT HIS GRANVILLE THE
GRANVILLE STATION IS LOCATED
ALONG I..
EIGHT IT IS -- ONE STATION WEST
OF SD ISSUE -- SO -- IT'S A
GREAT LOCATION GREAT VISIBILITY
GREAT LOCATION GREAT ACCESS TO
TRANSIT -- WE HAVE UP.
JUST A LITTLE OVER NINETY ACRES
THERE BUT JUST UNDER FIVE ACRES
ARE ACTUALLY DEVELOP MOBILE AND
THE REST WILL EITHER GO TO HELP
RUNOFF CREEK DEVELOPMENT OR THE
TRANSIT CENTER ITSELF IS THERE.
THIS IS AN INTERESTING PROJECT
BECAUSE OF THOSE DEVELOPER WE
SPLIT THOSE UP WE HAVE TO
DEVELOPERS WORKING IT GRAY STAR --
IT AS WELL AS AFFIRMED AGREE
STAR IS GOING TO DEVELOP A
MARKET RATE PRODUCT -- BASICALLY
SHOULD A STUDENT MARKET RATE
HOUSING -- THAT'S GOING TO GO IN
THERE A FIRM JUST GONNA DO A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX UNITS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
IN THE FORTY SIXTY AND 80% OF A
AYE MINE -- ALL TOTAL WILL HAVE
OVER A THOUSAND RESIDENTS AT
THAT LOCATION.
AND THE REVENUE THAT WE GENERATE
FROM THE MARKET RATE ONE HE IS --
IT IS IS GOING TO HAVE PROBABLY
HELP WITH TRANSIT PASSES -- WERE
REALLY GOING TO TRY TO STIMULATE
RIDERSHIP.
UNDERSTAND THOUGH THAT WHEN WE
ENTER INTO THE AFFORDABLE --
ARENA AS OPPOSED TO MARKET RATE.
OF THEN LIKELY WE'RE GOING TO
GIVE UP SOME SUBSTANTIAL REVENUE
IN IN DOING THAT AND THE RATE
DIFFERENCES.
OR THE RETURN TO MTS -- BETWEEN
THESE TWO DEVELOPMENTS IS FAIRLY
SUBSTANTIAL BUT WE'RE HOPING
THAT WE'RE GONNA MAKE IT UP IN
TERMS OF CERTAINLY A COMMUNITY
PRIORITY -- BUT SECONDLY -- TO
GENERATE RIDERSHIP FOR US -- THE
NEXT ONE I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
HIS PALM AVENUE TROLLEY IT'S ON
THE UC SAN DIEGO BLUELINE AND
WAY DOWN SOUTH ABOUT FOUR ACRES
WE'VE GOT TO TO DEVELOPMENTS
HAPPENING THERE.
NATIONAL COR WILL DO THE
AFFORDABLE WANTED 23260% A WIDE
AND MALAKIAN FEEL -- CORPORATION --
WILL DO THE OTHER WANTED ABOUT A
HUNDRED UNITS AND IT'S GOING TO
BE EIGHTY ONE TWO HUNDRED AND
50% AIRLINE.
SO RIGHT IN THE ZONE THAT YOU
ALL ARE ARE FOCUSING ON YOU KNOW
I THINK BOTH DEVELOPMENTS
ANTICIPATE ACCESS THE SUBSIDIES
TO MAKE THIS THING WORK --
THEY'RE LOOKING AT THAT RIGHT
NOW ESPECIALLY IN VIEW OF THE
BOARD'S IMPENDING DECISION -- TO
USE PREVAILING WAGE SO I THINK
THE HON IF THE 8210050% A I'M I
CERTAINLY IS GOING TO BE LOOKING
CLOSELY AT THAT.
STORE NEGOTIATIONS RIGHT NOW --
BUT THAT WILL ALSO INCLUDE A
MOBILITY ANOTHER.
YOU KNOW -- OTHER.
REALLY CONTEMPORARY THINGS FOR
TRANSITS WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT
THAT.
THE LAST ONE THAT I'M REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT IS RIGHT HERE IN
DOWNTOWN SAN DIEGO AT IN OUR
OFFICES AT TWELFTH AND IMPERIAL.
AND THAT'S OUR BUILDING THERE
WERE ON THE NINTH AND TENTH
FLOOR -- AND THE THE THE
PROPERTIES TO THE RIGHT OF THAT
WE HAVE OF ACQUIRED OVER THE
LAST -- TEN YEARS -- WHEN
PROPERTY WAS CHEAP -- BUT WE
BOUGHT THOSE AND NOW THAT'S
ALMOST A FULL BLOCK THAT'S
AVAILABLE FOR DEVELOPMENT.
WE HAVE A TRANSIT CENTER NOW
THERE WE WANT TO EXPAND THAT
TRANSIT CENTER BECAUSE THAT HOPE
LOCATION IS BECOMING.
A VERY POPULAR WITH A LOT OF NEW
SERVICE.
SO IN IN ITS.
ON IMPERIAL -- TO THE NORTH
FOURTEENTH TO THE EAST EAST
TROLLEY TRACKS TO THE SOUTH.
AND WE'D LIKE TO DEVELOP --
PROPERTY THERE WOULD PRIVATE
DEVELOPERS ALSO BUILD OUT AN
EXPANDED TRANSIT CENTER AND
POSSIBLY EVEN SOME OFFICE SPACE --
THE SITE ANALYSIS WE DONE IS
VERY EXCITING COULD BE UP TO
FORTY SEVEN STORIES -- POTENTIAL
FOR FIVE HUNDRED UNITS A PLUS
OFFICE WE'RE GONNA BE WERE
WORKING ON AN RFQ RIGHT NOW. TO
GAIN DEVELOPMENT PROPOSALS THIS
SUMMER -- THIS COULD BE A GREAT
CANDIDATE FOR MIDDLE INCOME
HOUSING -- BUT YOU KNOW WE ALSO
WERE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT.
IT YOU KNOW HOW MUCH CAN OCCUR
IN STILL AT LEAST HAVE A
POSITIVE RETURN TO US -- FOR
UTILIZING THAT PROPERTY SO WE'LL
BE WATCHING THAT AND HOPEFULLY
THEY'LL BE GRANTS AVAILABLE AT
LEAST FOR THE TRANSIT
IMPROVEMENTS -- THEY WE WANT TO
DO THAT WILL TAKE SOME OF THE
PRESSURE OFF THAT -- HERE'S SOME
OF THE MACHIN -- RENDERINGS THAT
SHOWN YOU CAN YOU CAN SEE IT
KIND OF ON THE ON THE THE RIGHT
THERE WHERE THE CLOCK TOWER IS
IN THE MTS TEN STORY BUILDING SO.
THEY COULD REALLY BE SIZEABLE
STRUCTURES -- IN JUST IN
CONCLUSION -- YOU KNOW WHEN
PEOPLE ARE ARE LOOKING INTO
GETTING TO THE FOR DOUBLE
HOUSING -- YOU KNOW ESPECIALLY
WHERE IS -- THINGS LIKE
PREVAILING WAGE THAT WILL --
MAKE IT DIFFICULT TO CREATE
HOUSING THAT'S MARKETABLE
THERE'S GOING TO HAVE TO BE --
SUBSIDIES AND WE'RE PROBABLY
GONNA TAKE -- LESS OF A
FINANCIAL GAIN -- THAN WE USED --
TO AND ALSO I I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT WHENEVER AGENCIES
ARE DOING -- THINGS LIKE THIS
ESPECIALLY US THEY REALLY NEED
TO SUPPORT AT THE COMMUNITIES
THEY RAN THE CITY'S -- LIKE SAN
DIEGO WE LOOSE WE RELAX THE
PARKING REQUIREMENTS ZONING
REGULATIONS IT CETERA TO MAKE
THESE PROJECTS WORK AND AND NOT
TO OVERLOOK THESE PROJECTS WITH
ADDITIONAL COSTS THAT MAKE IT
HARDER TO MAKE THINGS WORK.
AND I THINK THAT'S EXCITING
STUFF IT IS KIND OF EXCITING AS
A FORMER BOARD MEMBER RIGHT SOME
OF THESE THINGS STARTED DOES
THAT MEAN PLANTS EFFECTED BUT TO
SEE THAT WHAT'S.
COMING THROUGH NOW IS IS IS
REALLY IMPRESSIVE -- YEAH.
I THINK I THINK POLITICIANS
SHOULD -- CARDS BEFORE THEY
LEAVE I MEAN IN TERMS OF THE
LESSON THAT YOU'RE LEARNING NOW
AS YOU MOVE FORWARD SOMEBODY'S
PROJECT SOME OF OUR APPROVAL YOU
ALREADY HAVE -- DEVELOPERS ON
BOARD AND YOU KIND OF GOING
THROUGH SOMETHING STATE WILL BE
IN THAT PROCESS -- BEFORE TOO
MUCH LONGER -- IT IS LOOKING AT
A FEW OF THE QUESTIONS IN THE
YOU KIND IT GOT TO WHERE I WAS
INTERESTED IN.
THE THE BOARD IS MADE A POLICY
DECISION TO PRIORITIZE VERY LOW
AND LOW INCOME HOUSING ON THE
SIDES BUT THAT'S NOT TO SCREW
MIDDLE INCOME.
PROPERTIES ISN'T IN THE CASE
RIGHT NOW HE'S YEAH THAT'S
CORRECT AND THE THE SENATE SIDE
IS -- 420% AFFORDABLE.
YOU KNOW AT THE LOW LOW INCOME.
BUT IT'S NOT TO EXCLUDE ANYTHING
ELSE.
OKAY SO A IN BECAUSE AND YOU
MENTIONED THAT THAT WAS IN HOPES
THAT THESE LOWER INCOME WRITERS
WOULD BE MORE LIKE A LOWER
INCOME RESIDENTS TO BE MORE
LIKELY TO BE TRANSIT RIDERS I
WAS KINDA.
SOME OF THE TOP FIVE TO BE ON
THE PUBLIC USE OF THE PROPERTY
AND YOU KNOW IN THE PUBLIC.
GOOD OF OF BUILDING MORE TO
SUBSIDIZE HOUSING I WELL I ALSO
THINK THAT EIGHTY TO A 120% IS A
GOOD TRANSIT MARKET.
TO THAT'S WHAT I WAS GETTING OUT
YEAH I MEAN I ABSOLUTELY THINK.
SO -- YOU KNOW IT IT'S ALL ABOUT
WHAT CAN WORK ON PROPERTY YOU
KNOW WE'VE TALKED TO A BUNCH OF
DEVELOPERS AND AND AND IF YOU
KNOW I'M STILL HOPEFUL THAT EVEN
WITH THE PREVAILING WAGE WERE
STILL GONNA GET DEVELOPED.
HEY YOU KNOW I THINK A LOT OF IT
IS RATTLING OF SORTS A LITTLE
BIT AND AND YOU KNOW THEY'LL
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO IT WHERE
THERE'S A WILL THERE'S A WAY.
YEAH -- YOU KNOW I'D LIKE THAT
AFFORDABLE -- WORKING -- MIDDLE
INCOME LEVEL -- BECAUSE I THINK
THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT
WORKING IN OUR LOWER THAT IN OUR
LOCAL ECONOMY.
AND THEY'RE THE ONES THAT NEED
THE MOST HELP WITH WITH HOUSING
ALSO YEAH.
SO -- HOPEFULLY HOPEFULLY THAT
BECOMES PART OF IT IS SPECIALLY
AT TWELVE IMPERIAL THAT WOULD BE
GREAT.
I'D APPRECIATE THIS FORTY SEVEN
STORIES YOU CAN DO THAT MUCH
THERE I MEAN THAT'S YEAH I MEAN
YOU COULD DO A LOT WITH THAT
KIND OF DEVELOPMENT ON YEAH --
ON THE GRANT FIELD TROLLEY
STATION YOU MENTIONED THAT THE
TWO PROJECTS WITHIN THE ONE
PROJECT WHAT ARE THE SIZE OF THE
UNIT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT IN
TERMS OF THE DIFFERENT --
HUNDRED FIFTY SIX UNITS ARE
THOSE MULTI BEDROOM STUDIOS --
YEAH IT'S EVERYTHING FROM STUDIO
TO THREE BEDROOM ON THE OF FARMS
SIDE AND ON THE STUDENT ORIENTED
HOUSING THEY'RE NOT CALLING A
DORMITORY -- IT'S ACTUALLY --
MULTIPLE BEDROOMS UP TO FOUR
BEDROOMS AROUND A SINGLE LIVING
SPACE SO THAT'S WHY YOU GET SO
MANY PEOPLE HOUSE AND SAID JUST
SMALL AREA IT'S LIKE SOME OF THE
SUITE.
OF HOUSING THAT STF SHE WAS YEAH.
YEAH I SEE THIS PROJECT IN THE
PAST I WAS CURIOUS IF THAT'S THE
OPPOSITE THAT.
THE HOUSING TYPE THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT -- WAS GOT HERE
BUT IN THE MIDDLE INCOME UNITS
AT THE PALM AVENUE STATION I
DON'T KNOW DOES A GREAT JOB --
AND THAT'S EARLIER THE PROCESS
THE RIGHT YOU IT'S IT'S FURTHER
ALONG THAN TWELVE AND IMPERIAL
IT'S NOT AS FAR IS A GREAT FILM
SO -- THEY'RE LOOKING AT THEIR
NUMBERS RIGHT NOW -- AND YOU
KNOW VERY SHORTLY WE HOPE TO
SIGN A DDA WITH THEM OKAY BUT
THEY ARE SEEKING TO ACCESS SOME
OF THE NEW PROGRAMS FOR THAT
MIDDLE INCOME IN ORDER TO MAKE
IT -- PENCIL OUT AND THE OTHER
THING IS IS THAT -- WE DO NEED
IS OWNING AND UPS OWNING.
BECAUSE THE COMMUNITY PLAN IS
OUTDATED AND WE'VE ALREADY BEEN
WORKING WITH THE CITY ON THAT
WHICH CAN BE PLAYED -- WOULD YOU
REMEMBER.
AFTER THAT'S ANOTHER SUGGEST.
AND PALM -- OKAY OKAY -- AND
THEN YOU HAVE A FOR A SITE IS TO
FORTY SEVEN STORES NO NO -- IN
ANTICIPATION OF TOUCHING YOUR
EXISTING BUILDING RIGHT THE
ECONOMIC SOME TOUCHING.
THE EXISTING -- GIN MILLS
BUILDING WOULDN'T WORK RIGHT WE
HAVEN'T SPOKEN THAT -- YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY.
THE MAJORITY OF IT IS IN CONTROL
OF THE COUNTY.
SO YOU'RE YOU SHARE DOLLARS
RIGHT.
WE HAVE THE GROUND FLOOR AND WE
HAVE THE NINETEEN TEN THEY HAVE
TO THROUGH.
EIGHT SO -- JUST GIVE ME DREAM
IF YOU CAN DO FORTY SEVEN STORES
ACROSS THE STREET WHAT COULD YOU
DO -- ON THAT JUST ABOUT THE
VIEW IN THE LIBRARY AND THAT
TELLS ME ON NOT IT'S FOR MY
HOUSE A COUPLE.
WE GOT TO HELP PEOPLE OUT --
OKAY -- THIS IS GOOD STUFF BUT
YOU KNOW I APPRECIATE YOU KNOW
HOW I CAN SAID HE BELIEVES A
TENDENCY THAT PEOPLE FOLLOW WHEN
WE DO -- AND I KNOW THAT OTHER
TRANSIT AGENCIES ARE LOOKING
ALONG THESE LINES IT'S JUST
CERTAINLY HELPFUL TO SHOW PEOPLE
WHAT THIS CAN LOOK LIKE WHAT IS
THE MIDDLE INCOME STUFF FROM
HONG.
THE STUDENT HOUSING TO
GRANDVILLE -- YOU KNOW I WONDER
ABOUT IT'LL BE ABOUT
OPPORTUNITIES YOU HAVE BUILT ON
THE RIVER WALK -- LIKE DO YOU IN
THE RIVER WALK GOLF COURSE FOR
PORTIONS OF THAT WE ONLY YEAH
THAT'S THAT'S COMPLEX STORY
RIGHT BECAUSE THERE'S A BUNCH OF
COMPOST OR THEY WANT TO PUT IT
THE YOU KNOW THEY WANT TO PUT A
NEW STATION.
YEAH AND WE'VE WORKED HARD -- TO
TRY TO GET.
OUR LAND.
AS PART OF THAT PROJECT AND WE
WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH THE CITY
IN THE CITY'S WORKED WITH US.
AND I THINK YOU KNOW THE ONE
THING THAT WE ALL GET OUT I
DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHEN -- THAT
WILL BE DEVELOPED BUT NOW AT
LEAST WE HAVE ACCESS TO THAT
PROPERTY THROUGH THE RIVER WALK
DEVELOPMENT BEFORE THAT WAS A
LANDLOCKED.
SO NOW WILL HAVE ACCESS OKAY AND
AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WE
WE'VE HAD THE DEVELOPERS AND I
DON'T KNOW HALF A DOZEN TIMES --
TO TALK TO THEM SO WE'LL JUST
HAVE TO WAIT AND SEE ON THAT.
HOW DOES CONVERSATION KEEP GOING?
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT WITH THE
LARGEST CASH ABOUT FUTURE
STATIONS EITHER THOSE ARE CREDIT
EXTRACTION OR MAYBE LIKE THE ONE
YOU JUST DESCRIBED -- BUT
LOOKING AND I'M GLAD THAT YOU
HAD INVENTORY OF EXISTING
STATIONS BY THINK ABOUT SOME OF
THE MOST UNDER UTILIZED ONES --
DAD YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW WHAT
WE CAN DO A WEB LOG WITH OUR TO
MAYBE THE POOR DISTRICT ENDING I
THINK SOME OF YOUR STATIONS ARE
SURROUNDED CLOSE ENOUGH TO
POORLY AND BEGIN THE SORT OF
OVER THIS ONGOING CONVERSATION
OF PUBLICLY OWNED PROPERTIES.
FOR WHICH THE PUBLIC COULD USE A
GREATER BENEFIT -- AND THAT YOU
KNOW THINGS LIKE SOMEBODY
MISSION VALLEY STATIONS -- THAT
I KNOW ARE SURROUNDED BY FOR THE
SUBURBAN STYLE RETAIL -- THAT
YOU KNOW CAN I WONDER ABOUT WHAT
WHAT THE THERE'S ANY OWNERSHIP
STAKE THE U. HAPPY ON THE
STATION -- YOU KNOW.
NO SHADE ON THEIR BROTHERS ARE
MORE BUT I MEAN I CAN BE DE IS
CAN WE CAN WE GET SOMETHING MORE
AT THAT STATION THAT WOULD BE
TRANSIT ORIENTED -- YOU KNOW THE
YOU YOU CATCH MY DRIFT AND YEAH
SOUNDS TO ME LIKE YOUR STAFF IS
LOOKING AT THOSE EXISTING
STATIONS NOT AND AND NOT
ALLOWING THE ONGOING DISCUSSIONS
RISING RAIN AND WHATNOT WHICH
ARE.
VERY -- DATE PRESIDENT MINE --
BUT GOING BACK TO CITIES
EXISTING STATIONS WHERE MORE CAN
BE DONE I THINK IS THE RIGHT
APPROACH.
YEAH I THINK IT'S A MINDSET ALSO
I MEAN WITH T. O. D..
YOU KNOW FOR FOR ME IT ALWAYS
HAS A DIFFERENT MEETING BECAUSE
WE RUN TRANSIT.
BUT EVEN WHEN I SEE DEVELOPMENTS
AND AND I SEE SOME OF THE DANCER
STUFF LOCATED A FURTHER.
FURTHER DISTANCE FROM IT WHEN
YOU WANT THAT STUFF RIGHT THERE.
SO THAT YOU HAVE THE GREATEST
PROPENSITY FOR TRANSIT USE.
I THINK IT'S LITTLE THINGS LIKE
THAT THAT WE CAN.
WE CAN DO TO TO TO MAKE IT EVEN
MORE.
ATTRACTIVE [INAUDIBLE]
TRANSIT [INAUDIBLE]
GREAT.
AWESOME THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP -- OUR
NEXT PANEL -- IS A PANEL -- ONE
IF SHE COULD DEFINITELY OF THE
LEAST LOW IS THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CITY CITY GOES DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES DEPARTMENT.
SHE'S GOING TO DISCUSS THE
PERMIT STREAMLINING ACT SOME
EXPERIENCE OF THE CITY STATE IS
GOING TO IMPLEMENTING THIS ACT --
HE'S ALWAYS WONDERFUL TO SEE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
CANADIAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEVEN MEMBER
GLORIA AND A PLEASURE TO BE HERE
TODAY -- I I HAVE TO ADMIT I WAS
A LITTLE BIT FRAZZLED ABOUT THE
PERMISSION MONEY ACT BECAUSE AND
IT COULD BE CLASSIFIED AS BORING
BUT WE'RE GONNA MAKE IT EXCITING
AND IT'S GONNA BE GREAT -- SO
YEAH NOT WORK IT'S NOT A DRY
TOPIC ANYMORE -- WE'RE GONNA
MAKE IT A LITTLE MORE
CONVERSATIONAL I'M AN OFFER YOU
SOME PERSPECTIVE TODAY TALK TO A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHERE THE CITY
OF SAN DIEGO IS ON AND MIDDLE
INCOME PRODUCTION.
AND THEN -- A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE PROCESS PROCESS IMPROVEMENTS
AND THEN JUST SOME IDEAS I HAD
ABOUT PERMITS STREAMLINING IN
GENERAL -- OPERATE PERSPECTIVE
ABOUT THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO'S
AND DEVELOPMENT AND THAT A
HOUSING UNITS BUILT PER DECADE
YOU CAN SEE.
FROM THE SLIDE THAT WE REALLY
PEAKED IN THE SEVENTIES -- AND
THAT DECLINE THAT HAS HAPPENED
SEVERAL DECADES LATER AND
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS A NUMBER OF
REASONS AND AVAILABILITY OF LAND
AVAILABILITY IN LABOR AND COST
OF MATERIALS THOSE ARE ALL
THINGS TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION AS WELL AS PERMIT
AND REGULATORY PROCESS.
I WISH I HAD A CORRESPONDING
SIDE THAT ACTUALLY SHOWED THE
INCREASE OF REGULATIONS AND FEES
THAT IS ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
MIGHT HAVE CONTRIBUTED.
TO AND THESE NUMBERS.
I'LL MAKE THAT SIDE FOR THE NEXT
PRESENTATION -- THIS THOUGH
REALLY DEMONSTRATES THE GAP THAT
I WANTED TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT SO
THE MODERATE OR MIDDLE INCOME
REALLY STANDS OUT I MEAN JUST TO
HAVE A CONVOLUTED EUROS -- AND
THAT BEING THE LOWEST PERCENTAGE
OF OUR REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ASSESSMENT THAT AND WE'VE SEEN
ACHIEVED IT THEN THE CITY.
IT'S JUST IT'S JUST MIND
BOGGLING AND WE REALLY DO WANT
TO TRY TO ADDRESS THIS WITHIN
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO BECAUSE IF
WE CAN REDUCE THE PRESSURE -- ON
THE AFFORDABLE UNITS BY OPENING
UP MORE AND MIDDLE INCOME UNITS
WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE FOLKS
THAT HAVE THE INCOMES THAT CAN
MOVE INTO THAT. EIGHTY EIGHT
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TO A 120% AND
MY AND SO -- WILL BE ABLE TO GET
MORE PEOPLE ON AFFORDABLE UNITS
IF WE INCREASE THESE NUMBERS --
SO WHAT ABOUT THE PERMIT
STREAMLINING ACT WHAT DOES THIS
DO WELL THIS IS A STATE ACT THAT
REQUIRES LOCAL AGENCIES SUCH AS
MY OWN TO MAKE DECISIONS ON
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS.
OR ON A QUASI JUDICIAL AND USE
DECISIONS WITHIN SPECIFIED TIME
MOMENT AND IT'S AN ATTEMPT TO
CREATE CERTAINTY BOTH FOR THE
DEVELOPER -- AND TO GETTING
THEIR PROJECT APPROVED -- AND
THEN ALSO FOR CITIES TO GIVE US
SOME TOOLS IN TERMS OF HOW DO WE
WORK I AM SO REALLY YOU KNOW.
WHAT COULD HAPPEN WITHIN THE
PERMIT STREAMLINING ACT IS THAT
IF THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO OR
DEVELOPMENT SERVICES FAILS TO
ACT WITHIN CERTAIN TIME LIMITS
IT COULD RESULT IN A PROJECT
APPLICANT COMING IN AND JUST
ALTERNATELY?
BEING DEEMED APPROVED AN
AUTOMATIC APPROVAL THE PROJECT
IT SOUNDS GREAT AND AND
EVERYONE'S DREAM EXCEPT FOR THE
FOLKS THAT WANT TO ENSURE THAT --
SAFETY OF THE BUILDING AND THAT
ADHERENCE TO LAND USE PLANS AND
AND OTHER REGULATIONS -- IT'S
IMPORTANT TO TALK ABOUT PERMITS
STREAMLINING THOUGH BECAUSE AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE ABOUT DIFFERENT
THAT COST INPUTS AND REASONS WHY
HOUSING GETS EXPENSIVE I
DECIMATED THAT. 3240% OF THE
COST OF EVERY UNIT REALLY IS
THAT I'M REGULATION AND AND TIME
TO PROCESS.
SO.
WHAT THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO IS
DONE IS PROVIDED -- INDEPTH
REQUIREMENTS FOR OUR SAID MIDDLE
PROCESS AND FOR APPLICATIONS SO
THAT WE DON'T EVER FIND
OURSELVES IN THIS POSITION SO WE
FRONT LOAD THE INFORMATION.
AND I JUST WANTED TO POINT OUT --
THIS IS MORE OF A PROFIT RATHER
THAN A HAND OUT BUT THIS IS A
THIRTEEN PAGE MANUAL THAT WE'VE
CREATED JUST TO GUIDE YOU
THROUGH THAT PROJECTS THE MIDDLE
REQUIREMENTS.
THIS ISN'T EVEN THE REQUIREMENTS
THEMSELVES THIS IS THE THIRTEEN
PAGE MANUAL HOW TO GET THERE ARE
REQUIREMENTS SO -- WE REALLY
DELVED INTO THE DETAILS TO HELP
APPLICANTS UNDERSTAND EVERYTHING
THAT THEY NEED TO GIVE US
BECAUSE WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO IS
LOOK AT YOUR APPLICATION AND
DEMAND COMPLETE.
SO THAT WE DON'T MAKE A MISTAKE
AND IT DOESN'T GET AUTOMATICALLY
APPROVED.
THE THING ABOUT THE PERMIT
STREAMLINING ACT THAT IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE IS THAT.
THERE'S STILL A KEEN NOTICING
REQUIREMENT SO HAVING THE PUBLIC
UNDERSTAND THAT IF -- IT
DEVELOPMENT PROJECT IN THEIR
APPLYING FOR A ZONE CHANGE OR OR
SOMETHING THERE THERE ARE STILL
PUBLIC NOTICE REQUIREMENT THAT
HAVE TO KEEP THE GENERAL PUBLIC
INFORMED ABOUT THESE QUASI
JUDICIAL DECISIONS.
AND FROM MY EXPERIENCE IN THE
EVALUATION THAT I'VE DONE WITHIN
THE PROJECTS THAT HAVE COME
BEFORE THE CITY MOST APPLICANTS
ARE.
ILL PREPARED TO DO THAT NOTICE
SEEING IN THE TIME LINE AND OF
WHICH THEY APPLY SO I ONLY SEE
ONE PROJECT ACTUALLY INTEND TO
USE THE PERMIT STREAMLINING ACT
AND IT WAS -- NOT EVEN A HOUSING
PROJECT IT WAS A TELECOM PROJECT --
AND THERE WAS A LAWSUIT BETWEEN
THE CITY AND IT WAS FOUND THAT
THEY DIDN'T DO THE ADEQUATE
PUBLIC NOTICING IN ORDER FOR
THEIR PROJECT TO BE DEEMED
APPROVED.
SO -- BUT LET'S TALK A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT THE PROCESS THIS
IS WHY YOU'D WANT TO BE DEEMED
APPROVED BECAUSE YOU REALLY WANT
TO GET FROM POINT A TO POINT B..
VERY QUICKLY AND AS YOU CAN SEE
IT THIS IS IN A LADDER WHEN WE
HAVE AN EXTENSIVE JUNGLE GYM OF
PROCESS THAT TAKES YOU THROUGH --
BOTH A PRE MEETING AN
APPLICATION A COMPLETE AS RUBIO
ALL THE STAFF ANALYSIS AND IF
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT -- NOT A
MINISTERIAL BUILDING PERMIT BUT
DEVELOPMENT PROJECT AN
APPLICATION THAT WANTS TO
INCREASE THE DENSITY ON A SITE.
WE'VE GOT SICK WELL WE'VE GOT
ENVIRONMENTAL DISCLOSURES WE'VE
GOT LOTS OF TECHNICAL ANNOUNCES
THAT WE REQUIRE BEFORE THE CITY
CAN CERTIFIED ENVIRONMENTAL
DOCUMENT.
AND THEN ALL THIS LEADS UP TO A
STAFF REPORT A HEARING AND THE
ABILITY TO HEAL BOTH THE PROJECT
TO AND DID OF OUR MENTAL PROCESS
SO.
THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD REASON FOR
THIS PROCESS BUT IT TAKES UP A
LOT OF TIME.
SO IN TERMS OF THAT ONE OF THE
OBSTACLES TO MIDDLE INCOME
HOUSING PRODUCTION REALLY IS
THIS TIME TO PROCESS THE ONE OF
THE SOLUTIONS IS TO MAKE MORE
PROJECTS BY RIGHT AND
MINISTERIAL.
AND IN AS MUCH AS THE STATE CAN
DO THAT -- FOR AS AND AS A WAY
THAT YOU HAVE HELPED A
PREVIOUSLY WITH AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
DENSITY BONUS THINGS LIKE THAT --
IT'S BEEN VERY VERY HELPFUL
CITIES IN GENERAL NEED TO
IDENTIFY WHERE -- RESTRICTIVE
ZONING EXIST AND THEY NEED -- TO
UP ZONE SO THAT WE CAN GET
BETTER DENSITY SO THAT WE CAN
GET MORE UNITS YOU SEEN -- HELLO
OUR NUMBERS ARE AND HOW HIGH ARE
TARGETS ARE.
AND SO THAT.
IN ITSELF IS A GOOD WAY TO GO
WITH IT THE STATE HAS DONE A LOT --
THE MOVE FROM LEVEL OF SERVICE
TO VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
ANALYSIS FOR TRANSPORTATION
THAT'S GOING TO BE A BIG HELP
BUT I'M SURE OUR OTHER PANELISTS
LATER WE'LL WE'LL TOUCH ON THAT --
BUT THE IN DEPTH -- STUDIES AND
ANALYSIS REQUIRED FOR SECRET IS
CLOSURES AND DON'T GET ME WRONG
I A YOU GUYS READ MY BIO I'M A
TREE HUGGER WENT TO UC SANTA
CRUZ I'M ALL ABOUT IT.
AND BUT IT'S REALLY THE
TECHNICAL ANALYSIS AND THE LEVEL
OF DETAIL THAT WE REQUIRE.
ON A CONCEPTUAL PROJECT IN ORDER
TO GET -- THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DISCLOSURES THAT ARE REQUIRED BY
SECRET SEE WHAT -- SO MIDDLE
INCOME HOUSING HOW IS IT
DIFFERENT WHAT DOES IT LOOK LIKE
WHY WAS I TALKING ABOUT SEE
BECAUSE SO MUCH WALL AND I
DELAYED MIDDLE INCOME HOUSING
AND I'VE HEARD A LOT OF
DEVELOPERS LATELY TALK ABOUT
MORE ATTAINABLE HOMES.
AND IT'S REALLY ABOUT WHAT WHAT
CAN PEOPLE AFFORDABLE IF WE GIVE
THEM WHAT IS THAT PRODUCT LOOK
LIKE AND SO WE'RE SEEING
DIFFERENT PRODUCT TAGS COME INTO
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO.
IT'S LESS HOUSE IT'S MORE
AMENITIES CITY SAN DIEGO --
REDUCED OUR PARKING REGULATIONS
SO THAT WE CAN FIGURE OUT HOW TO
INCORPORATE LESS HOUSE MORE
AMENITIES INTO THESE WALKABLE
MIXED USE NEIGHBORHOODS AND
THESE ARE REALLY THE
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT I'VE BEEN
ENVISIONED -- BY A LOT OF
PLANNERS AND FOR MANY YEARS SO
IN TERMS OF OUR MY PERMITS
REMINDING IDEAS ALONG WITH THAT
AND WE'RE REALLY LOOKING AT BUT
THE POTENTIAL TO TAKE THE OLD SB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE APPROACH
WHICH WAS.
REALLY HARD TO GET TO IT'S AN
OLD STATE LAW COLLABORATIVE
EFFORT BETWEEN A MULTITUDE OF
STAKEHOLDERS THAT SAID YOUR
DEVELOPMENT PROJECT ON TRANSIT
MEETS THESE TWENTY SEVEN
DIFFERENT CRITERIA.
AND YOU COULD ACTUALLY GET SEEK
WAS STREAMLINING WE NEED TO HAVE
MORE PROCESS LIKE THIS FROM THE
STATE THAT STILL GIVE PRUDENCE.
TO SEE WHAT AN ENVIRONMENTAL
DISCLOSURES BUT THAT CAN
STREAMLINE IT SO MAYBE WE DROP
THAT WAS DOWN FROM TWENTY SEVEN
REQUIREMENTS TO FOUR OR FIVE
INCORPORATE TRANSIT PRIORITY
LOCATION EFFICIENCY AND THEN
BRING IN THE NUMBERS OF THE
AFFORDABILITY TO GET TO THE
EIGHTY DID -- ONE TWENTY AND SO
AND IN CLOSING I REALLY JUST
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT -- AS
MUCH THAT THE STATE CAN DO WHEN
YOU PASS REGULATIONS TO GIVE US
THAT ENVIRONMENTAL COVERAGE SO
THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO PROCESS IT
LOCALLY KEEP THE RULES SIMPLE TO
FOLLOW FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
AND THE MORE COMPLEX THE MORE
DIFFICULT IT IS TO ACHIEVE
MEANINGFUL GAINS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE INVITATION TO BE
HERE TODAY.
IT'S A GREAT PRESENTATION THANK
YOU AND I ARE NOT TO BE JOB I
THINK OF YOU OFTEN WERE PASSING
LEGISLATION SACRAMENTO BECAUSE I
RECOGNIZE A LOT OF WHAT WE DO
END UP ON YOUR DESK.
VERBAL MEDITATION AND YOUR LAST
COMMENT IT'S A BABY A LEARNING
LESSON I HAD OF YOU KNOW I THINK
SOME TOOLS WE CREATE THEY'RE
HELPFUL BUT WITHOUT THAT
CLEARANCE -- IT DID IS IT IS
IMMEDIATELY HELPFUL AND YOU KNOW
IF YOU BELIEVE THAT IT IS A
CRISIS YEAH THIS IS NOTHING WE
WANT TO SPEND.
MORE TIME DOING SO YOU YOUR YOUR
YOUR COMMENT WAS HEARD IN HAND I
DON'T KNOW I SPENT ON THAT BUT I
I I GET IT.
GREAT DAY YEAH YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT APPRECIATE THAT -- WITH
REGARD TO THAT THE PRESENTATION
ITSELF THANK YOU FOR SHOWING
THESE NUMBERS -- IN TERMS OF THE
PRODUCTION -- OVER THE LAST
NUMBER OF YEARS I THANK THEM
OFTEN WHEN EXPLAINED TO PEOPLE
THE HOUSING CRISIS -- WHY THEY
SEE CRANES AND CONSTRUCTION
SITES BUT THEY DON'T FEEL ANY
RELIEF FOR THEMSELVES I THINK IF
YOU MEANT AND ALL THOSE ZEROES
REALLY ILLUSTRATE WHY THE FOLKS
THAT MIGHT?
HAVE THE WHEREWITHAL TO SHOP AT
A TOWN HALL MEETING -- NOT FEEL
AS THOUGH THEY'RE THEY'RE
THEY'RE RECEIVING THE PROGRESS
OF WHAT'S BEING BILLED TO REALLY
DOESN'T HAVE THEM IN MIND AND
YOU KNOW IT'S LIKE THEY'RE HERE.
IN NUMBERS THAT ARE PRETTY HARD
TO ARGUE I THINK IT'S FAIR TO
SAY I DON'T KNOW TO YOUR CONTACT
WITH YOUR COLLEAGUES ACROSS THE
STATE.
THESE ARE NOT UNIQUE TO SAN
DIEGO THIS IS REALLY TRUE THE
ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA RIGHT --
ABSOLUTELY ANY OF MY FRIENDS
ABOUT IT INDUSTRY IT IS EDUCATED
ME YEAH THE THE THE PROFIT
BECAUSE OF THE UNCERTAINTY OF
THE PROCESS THAT THE PROFIT IS
AT THE ABOUT MARK OF MODERATE --
THE SUBSIDIES AT THE BELOW AND
SO YOU JUST HAVE TO SORT OF WORK
AND SEC WHICH YOU KNOW I WAS
GONNA COME BACK TO YOU GUYS IS A
CAPITALISTIC SOCIETY THAT'S WHAT
THE MARKET DEMAND IS SO WHY IS
THIS NOT BEING FILLED IN.
BUT AGAIN IT'S THE IT'S THE IT'S
THE UNCERTAINTY OF PROCESS
COUPLED WITH THE LACK OF SUBSIDY
THAT JUST KINDA CONSPIRES TO
CREATE THE ZEROS IN.
ON THE TASK OF THIS COMMITTEE IS
TO TRY ZERO AND NO PUN INTENDED
HOT ON THAT ON THAT DATA BACK
COLUMN AND REALLY FIGURE OUT
WHAT TO TAKE TO TAKE THAT OVER
AND HAVE SOME OF THOSE ABOVE
MODERATE WHICH TO MY
UNDERSTANDING IS MORE THAN THE
MARKET CAN BEAR -- THAT WE HAVE
ABOUT A FUND IT'S OF UNITS AT
THAT LEVEL VACANCY AND WE BASIC
FIRST MONTH FREE AND ALL THAT
KIND OF STUFF -- AND CONVERT
THOSE DOWNTURN MORE MIDDLE
INCOME HOUSING WHERE I THINK THE
RETURNS PUBLIC PRETTY PRETTY
SUFFICIENT IT'S JUST A FRONT
LOADING COSTS AND IF THINGS JUST
MAKE IT PROHIBITS.
THAT'S RIGHT THE ABOVE MODERATE
IN THE END MARKET RATES.
YOU KNOW WANTED TO HOPE THAT IT
WOULD TRICKLE DOWN AND HELP WITH
SUPPLIES SO MUCH THAT WE CAN
REALLY BOOST THEM THE MIDDLE
INCOME SIDE AND WE HAVEN'T WE
JUST HAVEN'T BEEN SEEN THAT SO --
THAT THE LAND VALUES AND THINGS
ARE THERE STILL ARTIFICIALLY
HIGH AND THAT.
WEEK WE HOPE THAT EVEN MORE
SUPPLY IN ALL OF THE DIFFERENT
INCOME RANGES IS REALLY GOING TO
LOSE THAT.
YEAH I THINK THAT THAT NEEDS ST
RIGHT THERE THIS IS NOT TO
EXCUSE OR ACCEPT -- THE LOW
PRODUCTION FOR VERY LOW AND LOW
INCOME HOUSING CLEARLY MORE MUST
BE DONE THERE BUT THE YOU KNOW
THE NUMBERS ARE PRETTY CLEAR
FORTY FOUR HUNDRED UNITS AT THE
VERY LOW AND LOW INCOME IN
THIRTY THREE AT THE MIDDLE
INCOME.
IT'S NO WONDER THAT PEOPLE LIKE
MYSELF ARE TRAPPED IN WHAT
HOUSING THAT PROBABLY IS MORE
BETTER SUITED TO LOW INCOME
PEOPLE WE JUST SIMPLY CAN'T
AFFORD TO MAKE THE NEXT RUNG.
ON THE HOUSING -- I WOULD IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX APARTMENT --
THAT IRAN -- I'M SURE IT WAS
LUXURIOUS IN -- NINETEEN SEVENTY
SIX WHEN JACK TRIPPER MRS ROPER
LIVE THERE BUT IT'S TWENTY
NINETEEN IT IS IT IS PROBABLY
BETTER SUITED FOR SOMEONE WHO
DOES NOT HURT WHEN A CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATOR EARNS -- BUT AGAIN
YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S IT'S
DIFFICULT TO MAKE THAT LAST RUN
BACK -- TO JEANS VISITATION OF
WHAT IT TAKES -- TERMS OF INCOME
ABLE TO AFFORD TO BUY SOMETHING
RIGHT AND THAT'S THAT'S THE
DISCONNECT AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
COMMITTEES ABOUT -- IT AGAIN
YOUR TO PRESENTATIONS I THINK
YEAH COME TOGETHER NICELY THAT
DEPICT A PICTURE OF THE
EXPERIENCE AND THEN YOU GO FOR
THE BY EXPLAINING WHAT CAN BE
DONE AND I WOULD POINT OUT THE
CURRENT STREAMLINING ACTIVE
MEMBER SERVICES FROM THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES.
AS WELL.
IT IS -- A GOOD THAT YOUR GRAPH
IN TERMS OF PRODUCTION ONE WOULD
ARGUES IS HELPING THAT MUCH
RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE IF IT WAS
PASSED IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
AND GET YOUR PRODUCTION --
PERSON THE BAR GRAPH CONTINUE TO
FALL WE HAVE TO SAY THAT MAYBE
THIS IS WORTH TAKING A LOOK AT
LIKE ANY PIECE OF LEGISLATION I
WOULD ABSOLUTELY THINK THAT IT
WAS SOME THAT WE CAN TAKE A LOOK
AT IN IN FOR EVERYONE WHO WE
KNOW THERE'S A THIRD RAIL.
THE SECOND HOUSE STUFF LIKE THAT
BUT I HAVE NEVER PASSED A PIECE
OF LEGISLATION WAS PERFECT ON
DAY.
ONE AND THEY ONLY GETS MORE IN
PERFECT WITH THE PASSAGE OF TIME
RIGHT AND SO IT IS IT AS YOU SAY
AS A AS A COMMITTEE TREE HUGGER
WHICH I WOULD CONSIDER MYSELF TO
BE AS WELL -- YOU KNOW IT ISN'T
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO REMOVE OR
ELIMINATE SOMETHING BUT IT IS TO
SAY THAT EVERYTHING NEEDS
UPDATING I DO THAT UPDATING OF
CIRCUMSTANCE AND AND REALITIES
ON THE GROUND -- I'M NOT SURE
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN AT THE
MIDDLE INCOME PART OF OUR
COMMUNITY WAS TO THE Q. LI
IMPACTED AS IT IS NOW AND SO --
IT'S A GENERAL INVITATION FOR
PEOPLE JOBS LIKE MY TO DO
SOMETHING RIGHT WHICH IS -- BUT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY HOW TO
GET TO THE ACTION PART WHICH IS
WHERE THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
YOU WERE MAKING AND I LIKE A
JUNGLE GYM REFERENCE -- THAT
LATTER JUNGLE GYMS IT'S A FUN
COMMITTEE HEARING -- BUT WHAT I
THINK I HEARD YOU SAYING IS THAT
THERE IS A TAKE ANOTHER EXAMPLE
OF A MORE RECENT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION SB THREE SEVENTY
FIVE WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS
HELPFUL BUT IT'S NOT AS HELPFUL
AS IT COULD BE.
MAYBE THAT'S A LEGISLATIVE IDEA
FOR THIS COULD BE COMMITTEE TO
CONSIDER -- FOR FUTURE
LEGISLATIVE SESSION.
YEAH I DEFINITELY THINK THAT
THAT WOULD KIND OF KNOWING WHAT
WE KNOW NOW AND WHERE WE ARE AND
IN IN THE CRISIS LOOKING AT
THOSE CRITERIA THAT REALLY ARE
ABOUT THE PROJECTS THAT WE WANT
TO SEE A LONG HIGH PERFORMING
TRANSIT -- WHICH YOU KNOW
IDEALLY IN OUR CITY IS ABOUT
THAT TRANSIT THEIR RUNS EVERY
DIED TEN MINUTES OR OR BETTER --
THAT IF WE COULD REDUCE THAT
COMPLEXITY AND YOU KNOW I HAD
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO ACTUALLY
SAID WE'RE GONNA CALL THE MID
COAST AND TRANSIT PRIORITY
PROJECT.
WE WOULD HAVE ALREADY BEEN ABLE
TO STREAMLINE SO ARE PROJECTS
ALONG THE MID COAST SO -- IF WE
CAN REDUCE THE COMPLEXITY WE CAN
BRING AYE I THINK THAT WE CAN
GET THE PROJECTS THAT WE WANT IN
A FASTER TIME PERIOD.
WE SHOULD GET TO TALK ABOUT THAT
OF THIS THIS COMMITTEES AS A
SELECT COMMITTEE WERE REALLY --
COLLECTOR OF IDEAS -- THERE ARE
INTENDED TO BE EVENTUALLY --
WANTED TO LEGISLATORS
LEGISLATION AND WE HAVE DONE A
NUMBER OF BILLS SO NOW THE
HOUSING COMMISSION THE CITY SAN
DIEGO -- AND OTHERS TO ACTUALLY
CREATE LAWS OF FROM THIS
COMMITTEE -- THIS -- AND SOME OF
THE SUGGESTIONS FOR THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS I THINK OF WELL
CREATING THAT THE LIST OF IDEAS
THAT WE CAN -- WORK ON IN THE
FALL AND HOPEFULLY PRODUCTION --
IN THE NEW YEAR -- I WOULD WRAP
UP -- I KNOW THAT WE DIDN'T ASK
YOU TO SO BE PREPARED FOR THIS
BUT AFTER SPEAKING WITH THE
STATE -- THE LAND TRUST -- THE
MTS I KNOW THE CITY SAN DIEGO'S
EMBARKING ON AN EFFORT TO LOOK
AT ITS PROPERTY AND TO SEE WHAT
IT MAY BE ABLE TO BRING TO BEAR.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS A WHAT THE
CITY IS CURRENTLY LOOKING AT IS
GENERALLY FOR THE VERY LOW AND
LOW INCOME -- MARKET BECAUSE
EVERYBODY'S THE SURPLUS
PROPERTIES THAT ARE BEING THAT
IT CURRENTLY.
YEAH THAT'S RIGHT I THINK THAT --
OUT OF OUR TOTAL PROPERTIES MORE
ONE OF THE LARGEST LANDOWNING
MUNICIPALITIES AND WE'VE
TARGETED ABOUT EIGHTY DIFFERENT
PROPERTIES AND AND ARE PUTTING
THOSE OUT AND WE'RE DEFINITELY
LOOKING AT THE LOW TO LOW INCOME
FOR THAT.
IS -- CONTEMPLATION OF WORKING
IN THE WORKFORCE SORT OF MIDDLE
INCOME HOUSING FOR THOSE
PROPERTIES.
THAT YEAH I I I I WOULD NEED TO
CHECK WITH OUR REAL ESTATE
ASSETS DEPARTMENT BUT I BELIEVE
SO.
I JUST -- WOULD PUT OUT AGAIN
AND GENERAL PLEA FOR WHOM I HEAR
MOST FROM AND I THINK YOUR CHART
AGAIN REALLY MAKES THE CASE FOR
WHY THAT SHOULD BE AT LEAST A
CONSIDERATION -- AND RECOGNIZING
THAT THIS IS NO SMALL TASK IN MY
OWN NEIGHBORHOOD THERE'S A
THERE'S A SUGGESTION OF COURSE I
AND I THINK THAT'S HEALTHY YEAH
IT'S A GOOD CONVERSATION -- BUT
MUCH LIKE THE STATE'S
CONVERSATION OF IDEAS SITES THAT
ARE IDENTIFIED THEY DON'T ALWAYS
PAN OUT -- ALSO IF THOSE DON'T
PAN OUT AS IDEAS FOR DEVELOPMENT
PERHAPS THERE IS -- SOME OTHER --
FOR FOR VERY LOWER LOW INCOME
PRESS OR OTHER USES THAT IN
THERE -- AND I YOU KNOW GET
WOULD HOPE THAT WE CAN
COORDINATE COLLECTIVELY -- I
RECOGNIZE THAT THE STATE
PROPERTIES A GREAT EXAMPLE --
THE STATE BUILDING DOWNTOWN IS A
GREAT EXAMPLE OF ALL OF A LARGE
PROPERTY NEXT TO A WHOLE LOT OF
CITY PROPERTY.
MAYBE THERE'S SOME CROSS
COLLABORATION THAT'S KIND OF THE
LEGISLATION EITHER USED AS
INTENDED TO REALLY FORCE THAT
CONVERSATION OF WHAT YOU CAN DO
COLLABORATIVELY FOR MORE PUBLIC
BENEFIT.
ABSOLUTELY AND YOU KNOW
REGIONALLY ACROSS THE COUNTY I
JUST THINK THERE'S SO MANY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP THAT WE JUST NEED TO
CONTINUE.
TO DIG DEEP AND IDENTIFY THEM
AND BUILD SUPPORT AROUND THEM SO
THAT WE CAN AND BOOSTED INCOME
PRODUCT -- TO START WITH THE
NUMBER OF UNITS THAT WERE
PRODUCING.
WELL YOU HAVE A LEGISLATIVE AS
WELL TO HELP ANYWAY HE CAN'T I
WOULD JUST SAY AT LEAST BY YOU
KNOW THE LONGTIME WATCHER CITY
HALL.
SEE A LOT OF YOUR PREDECESSORS
IN THE ROLE THAT YOU HAVE HI I'M
AND IMPRESSED BY THE NUMBER OF
POSITIVE COMMENTS ABOUT I HAVE
ABOUT YOU SPECIFICALLY IN THE
LEADERSHIP OF YOUR DEPARTMENT --
I JUST A CRAZY KEEP GOING AT IT
IS THE BIGGEST PROBLEM WE'RE
FACING I IT'S DIRECTLY RELATED
TO THE WORK DO YOU DO WITH THE
STAFF THAT YOU HAVE DO EVERY DAY.
HE SAID THAT YOU'RE HELPING
SOLVE A SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM FOR
THE GREAT MANY PEOPLE THAT I
REPRESENT I REALLY APPRECIATE ME
TOO AND I HOPE YOU KEEP AT IT.
MUCH APPRECIATED IT AND I THINK
THAT THE COMMENTS ARE WELL THOSE
ARE BY MY STAFF WHO WHICH IS
WORK TIRELESSLY.
TO DO WHAT THEY CAN TO MAKE SURE
THAT -- WERE MORE MOVING AS FAST
AS WE CAN TO GET THINGS
PERMITTED GET THOSE UNITS ON THE
GROUND WE HAVE GREAT LOCAL
PARTNERS LIKE THE HOUSING
COMMISSION.
AND WE'RE JUST GOING TO CONTINUE
TO WORK HARD TO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
IF YOU GET A MIDDLE INCOME
APPLICATIONS FOR THE TOP LIST
OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH -- THAT
BRINGS US TO OUR LAST PANEL OF
THE AFTERNOON -- ANYWAYS WE SAVE
THE BEST FOR LAST -- THIS IS --
A DISCUSSION ON NOT HOW GLAD
HOUSING PRODUCTION CAN HELP
CALIFORNIA MEET AT THIS IS KIND
OF GOALS WE HAVE TO LOCAL
EXPERTS.
WHO ARE AMAZING INDIVIDUALS AND
A CO CAPTAIN -- FOUNDER AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE CRIME
ACTION CAMPAIGN IN CODY WHO THE
CITY SAID EAGLES CHIEF
SUSTAINABILITY OFFICER I ALWAYS
TALK ABOUT WE TALK A LOT ABOUT
HOUSING IN TRANSIT -- THIS
AFTERNOON -- THEM THEN DIAGRAM
OF THOSE TWO CIRCLES -- IS
CLIMATE -- AND I THINK I SAID IT
BEFORE BUT TO GET THEIRS BOB
HOUSING IS THE MOST IS THE NORM
IS THE LARGEST ISSUE FACING --
THE STATE GENERALLY TODAY I
THINK THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT
CLIMATE IS THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE
FOR ALL HUMANITY -- AND THIS IS
QUITE ESSENTIAL BIG GLOBALLY ACT
LOCALLY SO WHAT CAN WE DO AT THE
STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL -- TO TO
BE POSITIVELY IMPACT THIS ISSUE
AND BOTH OF YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH FREE TIME IS EXTREMELY
VALUABLE I GREATLY GIVEN TO THIS
COMMITTEE.
I'M FLOOR JEWELERS.
GREAT.
I MEAN I JUST HAVE TO START BY
SAYING WE CANNOT FORGET THAT
ACTUALLY WAS DURING YOUR TENURE
AS MAYOR.
THAT WE CREATED THE IDEA OF
HAVING THAT SUSTAINABILITY
DEPARTMENT AND DIRECTOR AND
SOMEONE WHO IS GOING TO LEAD THE
CHARGE FOR CLIMATE ACTION AND A
LOT.
DREAM IT COMES TO LAST -- SO
THANK YOU PHONE NUMBER GLORIA
FOR ALLOWING US TO TESTIFY HERE
TODAY AND ADDRESSING THE
CONNECTION BETWEEN CLIMATE AND
HOUSING.
AT OUR MISSION IT COME ACTION
CAMPAIGN SIMPLE.
STOP THE CLIMATE CRISIS AND MAKE
CLIMATE A TOP PRIORITY FOR
POLICY MAKERS EVERYWHERE UNTIL I
MISSION IS ACHIEVED.
I THINK IT'S SAFE TO SAY NO ONE
CAN TOUCH OUR TREE HUGGER
CREDENTIALS IN THIS ROUND.
I KNEW I WAS THINKING CYCLE
FARTHER NOT.
AS THIS MEANS TACKLING HOUSING
POLICY BECAUSE HOUSING POLICY IS
CLIMATE POLICY HOW WE BUILD AND
RETROFIT OUR COMMUNITIES IS KEY
TO SUSTAINABLE FUTURE.
ALSO KEY IS HOW WE ENSURE THAT
THE HOUSING WE BUILD IS
AFFORDABLE TO MIDDLE AND LOWER
INCOME FAMILIES.
AS SENDING HAS REPORTED AND THE
STATISTIC MAY HAVE ALREADY BEEN
CITED OF THE NEW HOUSING BILLS
SINCE TWENTY TEN ABOUT 76% IS
CONSIDERED OUT OF REACH FOR
FAMILIES MAKING LESS THAN NINETY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
WE BELIEVE ONE OF THE SOLUTIONS
AND IT REINFORCES WHAT IS
ALREADY BEEN SAID TODAY.
THE TACKLES BUT THE CLIMATE AND
HOUSING CRISIS FOR THE MIDDLE
AND WORKING CLASS AND HOPEFULLY
LOWER INCOME FAMILIES TO IS TO
CREATE POLICIES THAT RESULT IN
MORE BALANCED AND VERY HOUSING
SUPPLY IN URBAN AREAS.
ESPECIALLY THOSE AREAS
TRADITIONALLY CENTERED AROUND
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES.
IF WE FOCUS ON BUILDING A
VARIETY OF HONG CHOICES LIKE
DUPLEXES TRI PLEX IS IMPORT
TAXES AND RESIDENTIAL CITY
NEIGHBORHOODS.
THESE KINDS OF MID CITY HOMES
COULD HELP KERR PRICES IN GIVE
MODERATE INCOME WORKING FAMILIES
AND SMALL HOUSEHOLDS LIKE
SENIORS AND YOUNG COUPLES MORE
AFFORDABLE OPTIONS.
THIS WILL ALSO HELP ADDRESS THE
CLIMATE CRISIS IN TWO WAYS.
NUMBER ONE SMALLER HOMES MEANS
LESS CARBON POLLUTION.
SIDELINE AND THINK BLANK I THINK
TANK IN SEATTLE TO STUDY THAT
DEMONSTRATES A FEW BILL TO BLOCK
THEY TO STUDY BUT HIS BILL TO
BLOCK OF JUST SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES AND ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE STREET A BILL TO BLOCK.
WITH DIFFERENT HOUSING TYPE SUCH
AS A DUPLEX AND TRIPLEX AND FOR
BY FROM THE OTHER SIDE IT IS
POSSIBLE TO CUT ENERGY USE 20%.
AN RTC ANOTHER NATIONAL
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANISM GOING TO
GET ORGANIZATION SAYS THAT NO
OTHER SECTOR OFFERS A HIGHER
POTENTIAL. FOR SINGLE SOURCE OF
ENERGY REDUCTION THAN
RESIDENTIAL EFFICIENCY WHICH HAS
A LOT TO DO WITH THE SIZE OF THE
HOME GOT A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN HOMES.
THEY DON'T USE ALL THE ROOMS IN
THE HOUSE AND THEY HAVE BUT THEY
STILL HAVE TO HEAT AND COOL THE
ROOMS AND UNFORTUNATELY THE
ENERGIES GOES UP.
NUMBER TWO INTEL CAN ALSO REDUCE
DRIVING.
AND SAVE EVERYONE MONEY.
THE KIND OF BENEFITS GROW MAY
INCLUDE THE POTENTIAL
TRANSPORTATION SAVINGS OF
LETTING PEOPLE LIVE CLOSER TO
EACH OTHER TO JOBS AND THE SHOPS.
ARE LIVING WITHIN WALKING
DISTANCE OF HIGH QUALITY TRANSIT
TO GET THEM TO THEIR
DESTINATIONS.
ANOTHER SITE SILENCE ON MY GO TO
THINK TANKS ANOTHER SITE WHEN
FIGURE SAYS THAT BOOSTING THE
NUMBER OF HOMES ON RESIDENTIAL
BLOCKS BY ONE THIRD.
CORRELATES WITH A DROP OF ABOUT
A THOUSAND MILES DRIVEN PER YEAR
PER HOUSEHOLD.
A 5% DROP EVEN AFTER CORRECTING
FOR HOUSEHOLD SIZE AND INCOME.
SO WHAT WE KNOW IS A DENSE
WALKABLE NEIGHBORHOODS PEOPLE
CENTERED PLANNING AND MULTI
MODAL TRANSIT NETWORKS MEAN THAT
WE CAN SPEND LESS TIME COMMUTING
IN OUR CARS.
AND CONTRIBUTING TO DIRTY AIR
AND CARBON POLLUTION.
ALSO HELPING TO IMPROVE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND CREATING CONNECTED
COMMUNITIES.
WE ALSO HAVE.
TO ACKNOWLEDGE IT ALSO MEANS WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
THE INEQUITIES OF THE PAST WITH.
THE INEQUITIES OF PAST ZONING
AND TRANSPORTATION PLANNING
PRACTICES BEEN LOCKED OUT
OPPORTUNITY IN PROMISE FOR MANY
FAMILIES AND STEAD CREATE THE
CLEAN HEALTHY VIBRANT.
DIVERSE HUBS THAT ARE ACCESSIBLE
AFFORDABLE EQUITABLE AND
INCLUSIVE.
GIVEN THE FUTURE POTENTIAL FOR
AND FILL THE REDUCE CARBON
EMISSIONS AND MAKE OUR REGION
MORE AFFORDABLE WE SUPPORT
POLICIES PROGRAMS AND
REGULATIONS THAT ALLOW
INCENTIVIZE INFILL DIFFERENT
TYPES SIZES AND COST.
IN FACT WE KNOW WE CANNOT MEET
OUR CLIMATE GOALS AND UNLESS AND
UNTIL WE EMPLOYMENT OR CREATIVE
AND INNOVATIVE HOUSING SUPPLY
OPTIONS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA KNOWS
MORE THAN ANYBODY.
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO HAS AN
AMBITIOUS CLIMATE PLAN.
LEGALLY BINDING.
BUT ALMOST MATCHES THE AMBITION
OF THE STATE'S COMMON PLAN THE
CITY MUST REDUCE OUR CARBON
FOOTPRINT HALF BY TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE THE STATE KIND OF PLAN GOES
OUT FARTHER IN TIME AND THEY AIM
TO REDUCE TO DE CARBONIZED 80%
BY.
TWENTY FIFTY AND ONE OF THE LAST
ACTS OF GOVERNOR BROWN WAS TO
PASS AN EXECUTIVE ORDER TO
ACTUALLY HIT CARMEN NEUTRALITY
BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE WHICH IS AN
EXTRAORDINARY TASK BUT A
NECESSARY. ONE FOR US LOCALLY
AND STATEWIDE TRANSPORTATION
REMAINS THE LARGEST DRIVER
CARBON EMISSIONS AND THOSE
EMISSIONS ARE ONLY GOING TO GO
UP.
IT REMAINS OUR MOST VEXING
CHALLENGE. TO TURN THIS TREND
AROUND WE NEED A SIGNIFICANT
SHIFT IN HOW COMMUTERS GET TO
WORK.
AND A REDUCTION IN VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED FOR THOSE THAT CONTINUE
TO DRIVE.
THIS WILL ONLY HAPPEN IF WE
BUILD MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SUPPLY YOUR TRANSIT AND JOBS.
ONE OF THE MAIN STRATEGIES THE
CITY HAS CITED TO REACH THOSE
GOALS HAS BEEN UPDATING
COMMUNITY PLANS AS WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER.
MOSTLY FOCUSED ON OPPORTUNITIES
TO UP SOME TO ALLOW MORE AND
FILL I'M HERE WITH HIGH QUALITY
TRANSIT AN ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION.
THE CHALLENGES THAT THE CITY IS
BASED HAS FACED AND STILL FACING
SIGNIFICANT PUSHBACK FROM
CERTAIN COMMUNITIES ABOUT UPS
OWNING.
EVEN BIKE LANES AND THE CITY HAS
OFTEN AND I'M YOU KNOW SOMEONE
UNDERSTANDABLY GIVEN POLITICAL
REALITIES CAPITULATED TO THESE
COMMUNITY DEMANDS.
AS A RESULT HOWEVER OUR
COMMUNITY PLANS.
ART UPDATE CAN YOU PLANS ARE
STILL NOT ZONE SUFFICIENTLY TO
MEET OUR CAPITALS AND THAT'S
JUST BASED ON DATA AND ANALYSIS
THAT THE CITY PRODUCES.
ON A POSITIVE NOTE HAS.
AT LEAST HAS MENTIONED THE CITY
OF PASSAGE WHAT POLICIES LIKE
THE DENSITY BONUS AND REDUCE NEW
PARKING.
MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS WERE
FINALLY DISCUSSING AT SOME REAL
TRANSIT SOLUTIONS REGIONALLY.
BUT TAKEN TOGETHER WE ARE STILL
NOT ON TRACK. TO REACH OUR
OVERALL GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
FOR TWENTY THIRTY FIVE AND WE'RE
WE'RE JUST NOT MOVING FAST
ENOUGH AND ALL OF THESE ISSUES.
THE OTHER CHALLENGE IS THAT ARE
COUNTY.
CONTINUES TO PRODUCE PROP WRITE
CHECKS ENCOURAGES DEVELOPERS TO
CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON BUILDING
OUT.
NOT UP.
THIS MAKES IT EVEN HARDER TO
PERSUADE DEVELOPERS TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO BUILD AND FILL IN
CREATIVE AND INNOVATIVE WAYS
THAT MEET HOUSING NEEDS FOR ALL
INCOME LEVELS.
AND IT THREATENS OUR ABILITY TO
MEET OUR CARBON REDUCTION GOALS
AND THREATENS AIR QUALITY.
AT THREATENS PUBLIC HEALTH.
WORSE IT MUST BE NOTED THESE
PROJECTS ARE NOT FOR THE MIDDLE
OF WORKING CLASS.
HELLO AND COST OF THESE HOMES
THE SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THAT IS WHY WE ARE OPEN AND
INTERESTED IN STATEWIDE POLICIES
THAT WILL ENSURE WE ARE CREATING
SUFFICIENT UP ZONING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MULTIPLE
HOUSING TYPES.
WE ALSO WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT WE
SUPPORT AND AGREED WITH THE NEED.
FOR HOUSING PRODUCTION ANTENNA
PROTECTIONS.
WE DO NOT BELIEVE TRICKLE DOWN
ECONOMICS WORKS AND HOUSING
POLICY.
WE MUST WORK HAND IN HAND WITH
SOCIAL JUSTICE ORGANIZATIONS
FIGHTING TO KEEP FAMILIES AND
HOMES PREVENT DISPLACEMENT AND
MINIMIZE GENTRIFICATION.
WE MUST FOCUS NOT JUST ON MIDDLE
INCOME HOUSING BUT ALSO ON VERY
LOW INCOME HOUSING PRODUCTION
AND WE KNOW YOU HAVE STATED THIS
IS A COMMITMENT OF YOURS AND WE
KNOW IT'S PARTY YOUR HEART AND
SOUL. TO TO FOCUS ON THAT BUT WE
AT A PUBLIC -- SITTING WE JUST
WANT TO BRING IN RE REINFORCE
OUR COMMITMENT TO ALL HOUSING
SUPPLY.
NON VOICE -- OPPORTUNITIES.
FINALLY WE HAVE COME ACTION CAN
PAIN ARE NOT EXPERTS IN HOUSING
POLICY.
AND IT IS CHALLENGING TO
NAVIGATE THIS VERY COMPLEX
SUBJECT.
BUT WE ARE ACT WE ARE EXPERTS IN
KNOWING WHAT IT WILL TAKE TO
MAKE OUR COMMUNITIES CLIMATE
SAFE AND CLIMATE READY.
INFILL HOUSING SUPPLY DIFFERENT
TYPES COST AND LEVELS IS
ESSENTIAL.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE TODAY WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO PARTNERING WITH YOU
TO SECURE A CLIMATE FRIENDLY
FUTURE AND BILL MAHER INFILL
HOUSING THAT WORKS FOR EVERYONE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME I'M CODY WHO WENT ON
THE DIRECTOR AND CHIEF
SUSTAINABILITY OFFICER FOR THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO ON THAT.
THE NEWS THE STATE ABILITY
DEPARTMENT THINKING ABOUT I FEEL
LIKE -- THE LIKE THE CLOSER OF
THE DAY I'M GONNA ZOOM OUT A
LITTLE BIT -- AND SOME OF THE
DETAILS THAT WE TALKED ABOUT
TODAY AND AND YOU'VE HEARD AND
IS JUST TO KIND OF MAKE THE
NEXUS CONNECTION HERE CLIMATE.
ACTION -- SO WE DON'T TO DOES
THE CALLS THAT WE DOCTORED AND
VERY AMBITIOUS CLIMATE ACTION
PLAN IN DECEMBER OF TWENTY
FIFTEEN THAT IS LEGALLY BINDING --
AND COMMIT FOR THIRTY TO
REDUCING ITS EMISSIONS BY 50% BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE WE ACTUALLY
ARE IN THE MIDST OF DOING AN
UPDATE.
ON BASS AND ALL THE CHANGES THAT
WE'VE SEEN AT THE STATE LEVEL --
AND LOCAL POLICIES AND
ACTIVITIES AND MARKET CHANGES AS
WELL -- IT IT'S I GET ASKED A
LOT WE REPORT ON THE ARE CLIMB
ACTUAL PLAN ANNUALLY YOU SEE
THAT LAST THREE COVERS OF THE
REPORT HERE -- AND I GET ASKED A
LOT IS NOT A LOT OF REPORTING
YOU KNOW TOO MUCH TO TO SEE AN
BENITO MOVE -- AND ARE YOU
AFRAID TO PUT OUT DATA THAT
SHOWS WHERE YOUR DEFICIENT AND
THAT'S I FEEL LIKE A BIG PART OF
MY JOB IS TO BE VERY HONEST AND
AN OPEN WITH THE PUBLIC ABOUT.
WHAT WE'RE DOING AND WHERE WE'RE
MAKING GOOD PROGRESS AND WHERE
WE ARE DEFICIENT AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS REPORT DOESN WE TEND TO DO
IT IN A VERY PUBLIC FRIENDLY
WAYS THAT?
FOLKS ACTUALLY WILL READ IT.
AND SO DO. TO REITERATE THE
POINT YOU'RE HEARING TODAY THIS
THIS IS THE SOURCES OF OUR
MISSIONS FOR THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO.
YOU SEE THERE'S A GAP BETWEEN
THE FIRST PART THE SECOND OF
FIVE YEARS AND THAT'S ANNUAL
AFTER THAT.
SO WE'VE SEEN SOME PROGRESS --
BUT IT'S SAD BECOMING A LITTLE
BIT MORE MARGINAL AS WE'VE
CAPTURED FROM THE LOW HANGING
FRUIT ONE POOR THING TO LOOK AT
HERE IS THAT.
THE DARK BLUE BAR ON THE BOTTOM
NOT AS OUR TRANSPORTATION
EMISSIONS THOSE FOLKS HAVE
MENTIONED THIS IS A BIG SOURCE
OF GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. FOR
THE CITY AND FOR PRETTY MUCH
THIS LOOKS SIMILAR ACROSS THE
STATE AND FOR THE STATE ITSELF.
THE TRANSPORTATION AND PEOPLE
GETTING TO AND FROM HOME AND
WORK IS THE BIGGEST SOURCE OF
EMISSIONS.
THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH.
I WOULD LIKE TO SHOW HOW IT
HIGHLIGHTS ARE AND REPORT AS
WELL WHAT I'M GOING TO FOCUS ON
TRANSPORTATION TODAY BUT WE DO --
PUBLISH ALL THE DIFFERENT
MEASURES THAT WE HAVE HERE.
I THINK IT'S EITHER JUST ONE
POINTING TO SHOW HERE.
ARE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS ARE
MAKING GOOD PROGRESS WE'RE ON
TRACK TO REACH OUR GOALS WERE
ACTUALLY SLIGHTLY AHEAD OF
SCHEDULE.
BUT BY NO MEANS ARE WE CAN WE
REST ON OUR LAURELS OR ARE SET
BACK BECAUSE WE HAVE A LOT OF
WORK TO DO AND JUST BECAUSE
RATING ARE GREENHOUSE GAS CALLS
IT DOESN'T MEAN READING ALL THE
OTHER GOALS THAT WE WE NEED TO
SEE.
HOW WE HAVE DEFINITELY CAPTURED
SOME LOW HANGING FRUIT MOVING
FORWARD -- WE TRACK ARE CLIMB
ACTUAL PLAN HERE AS YOU COULD
SEE BUT MOST PEOPLE DON'T REALLY
CARE ABOUT GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS UNFORTUNATELY FOLKS
ARE NOT THINKING ABOUT THAT
DAILY -- THAT'S NOT SOMETHING
THEY CAN MEASURE OR FEEL OR
UNDERSTAND BUT WHAT WE DO TRACK
AND WHAT IS IMPORTANT TO PEOPLE
OF ALL THE BENEFITS THAT YOU SEE
HERE SO -- WERE IMPROVING
QUALITY OF LIFE CLIMATE ACTION
WE'RE LOOKING AT IMPROVING
HOUSING AND TRANSPORTATION
OPTIONS FOR FOLKS.
AND WERE PROVIDING CLEANER AND
HOPEFULLY CHEAPER ENERGY TO OUR
CITIZENS WERE PLANTING MORE
TREES.
I'M WERE INCREASING COST SAVINGS
THOSE ARE ALL THINGS THAT PEOPLE
DO CARE ABOUT -- AND THAT'S
REALLY I I I HOPE IT'S THE NOT
SHOCKING TO ANYBODY HERE BUT
WE'RE NOT NOT ACTUALLY SOLVING
CLIMATE CHANGE WITH OUR CLIMATE
ACTION PLAN THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO.
BUT SHOULD WE SHOULD BE AND ARE
IMPROVING THE QUALITY OF LIFE
FOR SAN DIEGANS.
SO THIS IS THE BEST ACTION OF A
REPORT THAT LOOKS AT OUR BIKING
WALKING TRANSIT IN LAND USE
MEASURES AND THAT'S REALLY ALL
OF THE EFFORTS THAT WERE TALKED
ABOUT TODAY AND AND I WON'T
DWELL ON THIS FLIGHT BECAUSE
THEY KNOW WE'RE NEAR THE END.
BUT YOU COULD SEE WERE VERY
TRANSPARENT ABOUT WERE OBVIOUS
PLAN WAS AND WHERE WE ARE THE
LATEST REPORTS AND WHERE WE NEED
TO BE AND THEY WEREN'T OUR
NUMBERS ARE NOT WHERE THEY NEED
TO BE AT AND THAT TAKES A LOT OF
HEAVY LIFTING IT TAKES THE
PARTNERS IN.
THIS ROOM AND ELSEWHERE.
FROM ALL OF US HAVE TO WORK
TOGETHER TO INCREASE THOSE
NUMBERS BUT WE CONTINUE TO
REPORT THEM AS BEST WE CAN AND
ALSO TRY TO GET BETTER DATA
BECAUSE THE STUFF IS REALLY THAT
EASY TO MEASURE -- THE OTHER
IMPORTANT THING THAT WE TRY TO
DEMONSTRATE AS WELL OF THAT
ADDITIONAL BENEFITS OF GOING
BACK TO THAT.
QUALITY OF LIFE WE LOOK AT OUR
ECONOMY AS A AS A REGION AS A
CITY OR ITS GETTING CLEANER I
MEAN THAT'S A BENEFIT TO ALL OF
US.
AND JOB GROWTH IN THESE SECTORS
ARE ALSO IMPROVING SO YOU AND
THEN WHEN THE GENERAL CLIMATE
CATEGORY.
JOB GROWTH IS 13% -- WHICH IS
FAR FASTER THAN THE OVERALL JOB
GROWTH IN OUR ECONOMY LOCALLY IS
THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER BENEFITS.
TO WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE -- WITH
CLIMATE ACTION BRING THAT NEXUS
BACK TO CLIMATE ACTION HOUSING --
AND THERE'S A FAX HERE AND
YOU'VE HEARD SOME ANYMORE TODAY
SO I WON'T GO THROUGH THEM TOO
MUCH BUT AND I I THERE'S SEND
YOU CAN SPEND A GOOD MAJORITY OF
THEIR INCOME ON HOUSING AND
TRANSPORTATION AND THAT'S THAT'S
A BIG **** SO WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT TODAY AND CLIMATE.
ACTION IS A TOOL -- IT'S NOT A
FRINGE ISSUE IT'S ACTUALLY A
DIRECT TOOL TO BE USED TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES -- I AND
READING THROUGH THESE REPORTS
AND PULLING SOME OF THE DATA
TOGETHER HERE -- WEREN'T WE ARE
SEEING AN INCREASED -- RIDERSHIP
AND MIDDLE INCOME WRITERS -- I
THINK ANOTHER CITIES NEW YORK
IT'S NOT VERY STIGMATIZE TO
WRITE TRANSIT IF YOU'RE MIDDLE
OR UPPER INCOME BUT HERE IT
SEEMS TO BE.
JUST NOW CATCHING ON THAT IT'S
KIND OF A COOL THING TO DO.
I'M MORE EFFICIENT THING TO DO.
AND OF THE CITY OF CITY PLANNERS
AND AND FOLKS WORKING LOCALLY
AND AT THE STATE LEVEL WE'RE
THINKING ABOUT WHAT ARE CITY
SHOULD LOOK LIKE FOR THE FUTURE
NOT JUST THE FOLKS THAT ALREADY
LIVE HERE COME.
TO PUBLIC MEETINGS AND AND SO WE
HAVE TO UNDO SOME OF THE
POLICIES OF THE PAST.
THE THREE'S COMPANY ERA POLICIES
MAYBE AREN'T WORKING SO WELL FOR
THE GOAL THAT WE'RE HEADING
TOWARDS IN THAT THE NEXT
GENERATION THAT IS LIVING HERE
NOW I'M GOING TO BE LIVING HERE.
AND THEY WANT TRANSPORTATION
CHOICES FOLKS DON'T NECESSARILY
WANT TO DRIVE A LOAN TO BRING
TWO THOUSAND POUNDS OF STEEL
WITH THEM AND PARK IT ON THE
STREET WHILE THEY'RE AT WORK ALL
DAY.
I WANT OPTIONS IN THE SPACES AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I THINK
ARE CLIMATE ACTION IS OF THAT
BIG TOOL THAT HAS REALLY
TRIGGERED AND CREATE A TIPPING
POINT TO PUSH THESE.
INITIATIVES FORWARD SO WORKING
TOGETHER TO ALL THE OTHER ISSUES
THEN AND EXPERTISE.
YOU FOR TODAY AT ALL FOR THIS IS
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO HEAD OF THE
CITY SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
HAVING ME.
GREAT PRESENTATION THANK YOU
CODY I LOVE THIS LAST LINE THE
PREVIOUS.
HEARING OF THIS COMMITTEE WE HAD --
CALLING FROM SANTA COMMON
PRESENTS SOME OF THIS DATA IN IN
GREAT DEPTH -- TO MAKE THE
CONNECTIONS THAT EXACTLY YOUR
BULLET POINTS HERE MAKE IN TERMS
OF THIS IS A TRUE DRIVER OF
AFFORDABILITY IN THE STATE ARE
NOT -- THAT THERE IS A STIGMA
AROUND THIS EXTRA QUESTIONS
RIGHT TS ABOUT THE BOARD POLICY
AROUND FOCUSING ON THE HOUSING
THAT COULD BE ON THE SIDE TO A
PARTICULAR INCOME LEVEL WHICH IS
CERTAINLY NEEDED -- BUT REALLY
TRYING TO EXPRESS THIS NOT BEING
SOLELY. FOR LOW INCOME FOLKS BUT
REALLY FOR EVERYONE IF WE BEFORE
TO GET THESE GOALS AS THE COLD
MACHINE WHERE THE VAST MAJORITY
OF OUR OF OUR EMISSIONS COME
FROM FROM OUR TRANSIT NETWORK --
I PRIVATE DONATIONS BUT I
THOUGHT I THINK BECAUSE HOME HE
WAS PROBABLY THE MOST ON POINT
AND I WANT I WANTED SPACE
BECAUSE I THINK THAT --
SOMETHING FOR THE PUBLIC TO SAY
TO TO KNOW WE HAVE AN ANNUAL
RETREAT IS LEGISLATORS PROBABLY
ALL YOU HAVE IS YOU KNOW JOBS TO
YOU GOT TO YOU KNOW GET TOGETHER
AND YOU KNOW SORT OF WORKSHOP
WHAT YOU'RE GONNA DO FOR THE
YEAR -- ARE ASSEMBLY DEMOCRATIC
CAUCUS DID THAT BACK IN FEBRUARY --
WE'RE SIXTY ONE MEMBERS LARGE OF
ANY NUMBER LEGISLATURE SO YOU
HAVE A PRETTY GOOD
REPRESENTATION OF UP THE THOUGHT
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
THESE ONE HOUSE.
AND WE DIVIDED UP BECAUSE WE'RE
TOO BIG TO BE IN ONE GROUP
COLLECTIVELY -- IT'S SORT OF
SPOKE WITH SMALLER GROUPS ABOUT
WHAT WE THOUGHT THE BIGGEST
PROBLEM.
YEAH IT DIDN'T MATTER WHAT PART
OF DO YOU COME FROM NORTH SOUTH
COASTAL INLAND BAD BLUE OR
PURPLE WHEN WE ALL RECONVENE
ALMOST TO A PERSON IN EVERYONE'S
TOP CONCERN WAS HOUSING.
AND CLIMATE ENDED UP BEING IN
THE TOP THE BED SO -- IT'D BE A
REALLY SPEAKS TO THIS NEXUS OF
WHY WE WANTED THIS PARTICULAR
PANEL HAVE THIS CONVERSATION
HOUSE IS A TOP CONCERN IS WHAT
WE'LL HEAR ABOUT.
CLEAN BUT IT REALLY DOES A WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING ABOUT PEOPLE BUT
YOU DON'T SEE DOES END UP BEING
PRIORITIZE I CAN I CAN'T COUNT
THE NUMBER TIME SOME OF COMPLAIN
TO ME ABOUT A POTHOLE.
I CAN'T TELL YOU THAT EVERYTHING
COMPLAIN TO ABOUT A PIPE OR
ANYTHING UNDER THE ROAD ITSELF
ALTHOUGH BOTH THE PROBABLY IN
DISREPAIR -- IT BUT HE IS IF YOU
CAN'T SEE YOU KNOW PRIORITIZE IT
INTO WHAT HE PURPOSEFUL WITH
THIS PANEL WILL BE ELEVATING
BOTH THIS ISSUE GENERALLY.
BUT IT REALLY IS TAXES -- TO
HOUSING AND IS TRICKLE AFFECTED
TO TRANSIT BECAUSE THEY'RE ALL
CONNECTED -- I GUESS THE
QUESTION I HAVE IS THAT THE I'VE
REVIEW -- HELLO I'M SORRY THAT
THAT TO FINISH THE CONVERSATION
I THINK WE TALK ABOUT HOUSING IT
ISN'T ABOUT TRICKLE DOWN --
HOUSING DERIAN AYE PC MAKING
THAT AS A PART OF THE RECORD FOR
THIS HEARING I WANT TO BE
EXPRESSED ABOUT IT IS WELL YOU
KNOW IT IS ABOUT -- MORE HOMES
COUPLE WITH TENET PROTECTIONS
COUPLED WITH FUNDING TO ACTUALLY
EFFECTUATE THIS TIME WHETHER
IT'S THE INFRASTRUCTURE
ENHANCEMENTS THE COMMUNITY
AMENITIES ALL THESE THINGS
TOGETHER I THINK IS HOW CAN WE
ESTABLISHED OF THE LATTER IN A
FUNCTIONAL HOUSING ECONOMY.
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE ONE
CURRENTLY RIGHT -- IN SO IT'S
IMPORTANT TO SAY THAT IT'S
PRODUCTION IT REALLY ALL LEVELS
INCLUDING THE UPPER AND BECAUSE
WHICH FOLKS IN PLACE THE TWO BUT
IT'S RECOGNIZING THE INEQUITY.
IN EQUITY OF OUR CURRENT SYSTEM
WHICH IS THERE'S NO PRODUCTION
THE MIDDLE AND THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH AT THE VERY LOW IN AND SO
FOR GOING TO HANDLE THIS PROBLEM
EQUITABLY REQUIRES EVERYTHING.
THAT YOU SAY TED DISPLACEMENT ON
STUFF ARE REAL ISSUES -- IN THAT
EVERYONE HAS TO BENEFIT -- IF
WE'RE TRYING TO CREATE NEW
INCENTIVES A NEW.
NEW I'M CONVINCED MY QUESTION I
GUESS FOR BOTH OF YOU AS WE WRAP
UP FROM PEOPLE AND THE WAY YOU
SAID WHAT COULD THE LEGISLATURE
DUE TO HELP POSITIVELY IMPACT
HOUSING PRODUCTION.
OF WHY DON'T YOU UNDERSTAND HOW
IT DIRECTLY IMPACTS KLEIN IT --
EIGHTY HEARD AT LEAST TALK ABOUT
YOUR POTENTIAL -- AND THEN THE
TO SB THREE SEVENTY FIVE A DAY
IN THE PERMITS FREE MONEY ACT
YOU HEARD -- THE FACT THAT WE
NEED TO LOOK AT EXPANDING THE
AVAILABILITY OF THE LAND TRUSTS
TO PARTICIPATE IN CERTAIN --
SUBSIDIES WHAT WOULD YOU SEE AS
BEING THINGS THAT MIGHT COME TO
MIND WE SHOULD SPEND THE NEXT
NUMBER OF MONTHS DEVELOPING A
POTENTIALLY INTRODUCED THIS
LEGISLATION.
IN.
TWENTY TWENTY CONTROVERSIAL.
YEAH -- KNOWING HE WILL BE.
YOU KNOW WHAT COULD BE WORSE FOR
THE MAYOR'S I'M NOT SURE WHAT
SHE'S ALLOWED TO SAY BUT I
PERSONALLY THINK -- YOU KNOW
VERY CONTROVERSIAL SUBJECT BUT
SB FIFTY SHOULD BE CONSIDERED
MORE SERIOUSLY AND OVER YOU KNOW
CONTINUE TO HAVE THOSE TOUGH
CONVERSATIONS BUT LIKE I POINTED
OUT UNFORTUNATELY IN OUR
COMMUNITY PLAN UPDATES THEY'RE
NOT A ZONING SUFFICIENTLY FOR US
TO MEET THE KIND OF PLAN GOALS
AND ARE CLEMENTINE.
ONLY GOES TO TWENTY THIRTY FIVE
AND WE KNOW WE HAVE TO GET A
CARBON NEUTRALITY SO WE YOU KNOW
THAT'S JUST SCRATCHING THE
SURFACE WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH
OUR CURRENT COMMUNITY PLANS.
SO IT'S NOT EVEN ENOUGH NOW
LOOKING AT THE CHEMICALS AND WE
HAVE TO DO MORE SO I I DO FEEL.
I'M STILL BIG BELIEVER AND LOCAL
PROCESS AND ENGAGEMENT AS YOU
KNOW I'M I GO TO THE SCREEN
PLANNING MEETINGS I ENGAGE I
BELIEVE IN.
LOCAL CONTROL AND ALL THAT BUT
THE SAME TIME IF THERE'S A GAP I
THINK SOME STATE -- POLICIES AND
REGULATIONS -- MIGHT BE NEEDED
AND ANYTHING AND I DON'T KNOW
WHAT A BILL AROUND THIS COULD
LOOK LIKE.
BUT ANYTHING TO STOP SPRAWL.
IF THERE'S ANYTHING WE CAN DO I
MEAN YOU KNOW STUFF LIKE
PORTLAND HAS URBAN GROWTH
BOUNDARY OF ANY OTHER.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU CAN DO TO
STATEWIDE LEVEL BUT IT IS A HUGE
PROBLEM THAT WE'RE EXPERIENCING
ON THE GROUND.
I THINK BEING THE FASTER ON THE
WILD HEART ISSUES AS WELL RIGHT
NOW.
TO AND I WOULD JUST SAY I THINK
AND GET A HIGHER LEVEL OF ANY
ANY LEGISLATION AND AND
SUBSEQUENT FUNDING THAT COMES
DOWN TO THE LOCAL LEVEL FROM THE
STATE.
ON ON ANY OF THESE HOUSING
ISSUES CAN BE TIED TO OUR HAVE
STRINGS ATTACHED THAT SAY IF
YOUR LOCAL JURISDICTION DOESN'T
HAVE A CLIMATE ACTION PLAN OR IF
YOU ARE HITTING THE X. Y. Z.
POLICIES.
THAT YOU'RE NOT GONNA BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS FUNDING AND
THAT'S A BIG A HOOK FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES TO WANT.
TO WHAT ARE THEY BELIEVE IN THIS
AND REALLY SUPPORTED OR WHETHER
I DO IT BECAUSE THEY HAVE.
TO DOESN'T MATTER WHY THEY'RE
DOING THE RIGHT THING AS LONG AS
THEY ARE.
I THINK THAT'S THAT'S GREAT BOTH
THAT THAT'S OKAY FEEDBACK AND I
THINK TO GET THAT LAST PART
WHERE.
THE GOVERNOR HAS REALLY BEEN
INTERESTED IN TRYING TO
INCENTIVIZE LOCAL CITIES TO DO
MORE FOR THEIR PRODUCTION AGAIN
THIS IS WHY THIS IS ON OUR
AGENDA IS A THERE IS A CLEARLY.
TO KINDA SO SUCH A HOUSING
PRODUCTION BUT ABOUT THAT AND
YOU DID EXACTLY RIGHT ON AYE AYE
YOU GET TO COMMIT TO MEMORY BUT
THE NEW -- THE ACRONYM FOR
WILDFIRE INTERFACE AREAS I MEAN
THEY START TO SPEAK TO GET WHERE
SHOULD -- NEW HOUSING BE
PRIORITIZED ARE PROHIBITED --
THE GIVEN EXTREME COSTS TO
TAXPAYERS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IT WAS OF THE
WILDFIRES I THINK WE STARTED IT --
REALLY GREAT THAT I HAVE AN
APARTMENT CONVERSATION WHAT WILL
WE OR SOMETHING CALLED CAN MAKE
ONE FINAL COMMENT JUST TO ECHO.
WHAT SHE REYES AND I TOTALLY
AGREE WITH HER COMMENT -- AS A
MEMBER OF THE STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL WE ARE BEGINNING TO DO
SOMETHING UNIQUE I BELIEVE AND
THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE LOOKING
AT WHERE THE STATE DOLLARS GO.
AND WHETHER THOSE DOLLARS ARE
TIED TO THE STATE'S CLIMATE PLAN
FOR THE STATE'S KIND OF GOALS
FOR THE FIRST TIME SO I CLOSE
LIKE OR TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES.
SO -- IT'LL BE INTERESTING BUT I
THINK THAT'S ALSO GOING TO BE A
HELPFUL DATA POINTS TO SEEK TO
POTENTIALLY TIED DOLLARS.
TO LOCAL REGIONS BASED ON ONE OF
THEIR IMPROVING ON NOT IMPROVING
CLIMATE.
ELECTIONS I DOES A GREAT SORT OF
GENERALIZED GOES ON HOW WE TO
SAY OPERATIONALIZE SOME OF THOSE
INTO POLICY BUT THAT'S PART OF
WHY WE HAVE -- AMAZING STAFF AND
AND GREAT ATTORNEYS AND OTHER
FOLKS TO MAYBE CAN HELP US
FIGURE IT OUT -- AND AND THE
CALL YOU YOU HAD A BUNCH OF
INSTEAD OF A LARGE CONVERSATION
LEGISLATURE THIS YOU KNOW HOW
MUCH LOCAL CONTROL DO WE LEAVE
IT HOW MUCH IS A STATE PARTY.
CLEARLY ARTICULATE THIS IS A
MASSIVE STATEWIDE ISSUE NO ONE
CITIES GOING TO SOLVE IT EVERY
CITY HAS TO PARTICIPATE IN A AND
I THINK GENERALLY SANDY WAS
TRYING TO GO IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
YOU HEARD FROM -- THE STAFF
BEFORE WERE NOT MEETING OUR
RESPONSIBILITIES BUT WE ARE
TRYING THAT IS HONESTLY TRUE OF
EVERY CITY IN THE STATE.
AND SO THAT DELICATE BALANCE OR
ANYTHING YOU HAVE A CONVERSATION
WITH -- OTHERS ARE UTILIZING
FEAR TRYING SCARED -- THIS
CONVERSATION I ONE MOMENT FROM
IT -- WE HAVE TO DO IT -- YOU
KNOW IF YOU'RE ASKING IF ANYONE
IS SORT OF A CITY COUNCIL NO IF
YOU ASK NEIGHBORHOOD TO TAKE A
NEW DEVELOPMENT HAS TO THE
EXPECTATION THAT OTHERS ARE
DOING THEIR FAIR SHARE AND
THAT'S REALLY WHAT I THINK THIS
CONVERSATION IS ABOUT -- THAT SB
FIFTY IS VERY ONGOING
CONVERSATION I DON'T THINK SO
THAT THE AUTHOR -- BUT OTHERS I
DON'T SEE IT AS A AS A AS A DONE
DEAL -- I THINK THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE DISCUSSING REFINED HOW
DOES THAT PLAY OUT WHAT AWAITED
STILL POWER CITIES TO MAKE LOCAL
DECISIONS I THINK THAT GENERALLY
IS THE BEST PLACE.
BUT THINK IT'S CHEAPER TO YOUR
POINT TO HAVE YOU MEET BROADER
BIGGER GOALS.
PROBABLY THE BEST PLACE TO AND
AS I ALREADY SAID EARLIER I
THINK IT'S THE WORLD IS BETTER
OFF IN SAN DIEGO LEADS AND WITH
REGARD TO THE CLIMATE ACTION
PLAN.
SAID IT WAS THE MEETING FOR
SEVERAL YEARS NOW IN THIS REGARD
OTHER COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE CROSS COUNTRY AROUND THE
WORLD ARE FOLLOWING.
THESE EXTREMELY CITING AND FOR
THE STATE FOLKS ARE HERE IN THE
ROOM -- WHO ARE JUST BUSY IN SAN
DIEGO FOR THE DAY -- THE HOPE
YOU TO KEEP IN MIND AND AND AND
THE PARK -- THESE TWO WOMEN --
IN THE WORK THAT THEY'RE DOING
AND WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE
LOCALLY IS POTENTIALLY A CLASS
LEADING A WORK THAT CAN BE
EMULATED ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
HOPEFULLY EXPORTED ELSEWHERE
BECAUSE WE'RE GOOD HAS SO THOSE
CALIFORNIA SO GOES THE REST
NATION I THANK YOU BOTH VERY
MUCH FOR WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
THIS BRINGS US TO THE PUBLIC
COMMENT A PORTION OF OUR AGENDA
I HAVE ONE SPEAKERS LIVE
ACTUALLY DIDN'T CLEARLY
ARTICULATED WE HOUSE SPEAKER
SLIP SO OF ANYONE WHO WANTS TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE PLEASE
COME UP WITH A WERE STILL
FILMING RECORDING ALL THIS.
SEASON BALLING UP FIRST BECAUSE
YOU ARE THE ULTIMATE ROLE
FOLLOWED BY FILLING OUT LET.
BUT I SEE A LOT OF FOLKS HERE
WHO I KNOW ARE VERY WISE ON THIS
ISSUE YOU'RE WELCOME TO ADDRESS
JUST COME ON UP AND AND GET YOUR
COMMENT THAT YOU CAN -- SUPPLIES
BUT AFTERWARD -- IN THE INTEREST
TO BE AN EXPEDITIOUS SUSAN THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
[INAUDIBLE]
I THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SUSAN BALDWIN AND NOT --
I AM A RETIRED PLANNER WHO
WORKED ON HOUSING ISSUES THAT
SANDBAG.
FOR ABOUT OVER TWENTY FIVE
COMMENTS TO MAKE -- I UNDERSTAND.
AND BELIEVE THAT THEY TRULY
BELIEVE THAT THERE IS A LOCK OF
MODERATE INCOME HOUSING BEING
BUILT.
STATEWIDE NOT NOT JUST IN THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO -- I WORKED ON
REPORTS THAT.
COMPILED ALL THE DATA FROM THE
CITY'S -- TO SHOW HOW MANY UNITS
ARE HOW MANY BUILDING PERMITS
HAVE BEEN ISSUED.
AND I THINK ONE OF THE PROBLEMS
TOO IS THAT THE THE INFORMATION
ABOUT MODERATE INCOME.
MODERATE INCOME HOUSING ISN'T TO
WELL DEFINED.
AND SO I THINK.
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT -- TO
PROVIDE CLEAR INFORMATION ABOUT
WHAT IS MODERATE INCOME SCENE.
AND WHAT ARE AFFORDABLE RENTS
AND PRICES FOR MODERATE INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS TO AFFORD.
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN OF SOME REASON
HEARINGS -- AT THE COUNTY WHEN
DEVELOPERS ARE SAYING THAT THEY
ARE BUILDING FIVE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLAR HOMES.
AND THEY ARE SAYING THAT THOSE
ARE FOR MODERATE INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS.
AND THAT.
JUST ISN'T TRUE A MODERATE
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS AT THE UPPER
END FOUR FOUR PERSON FAMILY IS --
NINETY ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
A FAMILY MAKING THAT MUCH MONEY
CAN AFFORD ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY TO THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
SO I THINK WE NEED TO BE CLEAR
ABOUT.
WHAT MODERATE INCOME HOUSING IS
AND WHO CAN AFFORD IT?
AND MY OTHER -- POINT IS THAT
WHEN MODERATE INCOME HOUSING IS
PROVIDED AND I I'M GETTING TO
THE POINT WHERE I THINK IT HAS
TO BE.
DELIVERED IT HAS TO BE
SUBSIDIZED IN SOME WAY OR IT'S
NOT GOING TO BE PROVIDED.
AND I THINK THAT -- THERE NEED
TO BE DEED RESTRICTIONS TO
ENSURE LONG TERM IN
AFFORDABILITY BECAUSE WITHOUT
THOSE DEED RESTRICTIONS.
THOSE UNITS WILL NOT STAY
MODERATE INCOME [INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SUSAN EVEN AS ONE OF
JUST THE COMMITTEE.
HELLO THIS IS RESTRAINING
HIMSELF AS BEST HE CAN.
DEAR FRIEND A POLICY WONK --
OKAY ONE THAT WILL BRING US TO
THE END OF ALL OF OUR HERE AND I
WANT TO WRAP UP.
MY THINKING EVERYONE WHO'S HERE --
BUT SPECIAL APPRECIATION TO THE
MEMBERS OF MY STAFF -- WHO WILL
PULL THIS TOGETHER I'M CHRIS
HOBBY AIR SAPIEHA AND STEVE HELP
GOD BLESS DEVELOP RALLY DOES ON
HOUSING AND ALL THINGS GENERALLY --
THE COMMITTEE -- WILL CONTINUE
TO OPERATE AND WE WOULD GET IN
BY YOUR FEEDBACK ON LEGISLATION --
THAT WOULD BE WORTHY OF
INTRODUCTION -- IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY LEGISLATIVE YEAR -- BY
WAY OF REFERENCE WERE ON RECESS
RIGHT NOW THIS IS MY RECESS A
TIRE -- YEAH WE GO BACK -- IN
ABOUT THREE WEEKS TIME -- WILL
FINISH OUT THE LEGISLATIVE YEAR --
JOURNEY -- IN THE MIDDLE FALL --
AND THEN WILL REALLY WORK UP
THESE IDEAS MANY OF WHICH WERE
PART OF TODAY'S TESTIMONY A
CLEAN -- AND THEN A CLEAR
WHATEVER ELSE YOU WOULD LIKE TO
GIVE US -- WITH THE GOAL OF
INTRODUCING IT WHEN WE RESUME
THE LEGISLATIVE SESSION AND THE
RADICALLY EARLY DECEMBER BUT ALL
NATURAL FACT IN THE NEW YEAR SO --
WE CONTINUE TO BE FOCUSED ON
THIS ISSUE WE HAVE A HOUSING
COMMITTEE -- THAT I SERVE ON IN
THE LEGISLATURE STANDING
COMMITTEE THAT DEALS WITH ALL
ISSUES THAT HOUSING BUT THE
SELECT COMMITTEES PURPOSE AND
INTENTION IS TO FOCUS ON WHAT WE
CAN DO.
AS A STATE TO INCENTIVIZE AND
GROW UP IN A MIDDLE AND WORKING
CLASS HOW HOUSING IN THE STATE
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE OUR WORK CUT
OUT FOR US -- IN TODAY'S
TESTIMONY AND AND PRESENTATION
TO HELP US DO IT -- MY SAYS WHEN
I THINK -- ALL OF OUR FRIENDS --
IN THE DIGITAL WORLD WHO ARE
HELPING US TO GET THIS OUT TO A
FAR LARGER AUDIENCE -- THIS IS
NO ACCIDENT THESE BATTERIES
DON'T CHARGE THEMSELVES -- THE
ACCESS TO THE INTERNET IS NO --
THE YOU KNOW EASY PAYING -- FOR
PEOPLE LIKE ME SO I APPRECIATE
YOU GUYS AND YOUR HELP IN MAKING
SURE THAT WERE OPEN AND
TRANSPARENT TO THE GENERAL
PUBLIC THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE --
AGAIN OUR DOOR IS ALWAYS OPEN I
THINK ALL OF YOU KNOW ME I KNOW
THAT I'M NOT ESPECIALLY ANIMATED
ABOUT -- INSURANCE -- OR DMV OR
THINGS THAT NATURE -- HOUSING
HOMELESSNESS ARE THE THINGS I'M
PASSIONATE ABOUT IT'S WHY I'VE
SUCKED UP SHE'S SORT OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO HOLD THE CHILES
IN MY OFFICE -- TO CONTINUE TO
ADVANCE THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE
WHICH WHEN ASKED IF THERE'S TOP
THREE ISSUES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THEY'RE HOUSING
HOUSING HOUSING -- AND SO WE
NEED TO DO AS MUCH AS WE CAN --
TO TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE KNOW
THAT WE KNOW THAT'S A PROBLEM
THAT WE'RE DOING SOMETHING ABOUT
IT SO -- IF THERE'S NOTHING ELSE
WE STAND ADJOURNED AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME ATTENTION THIS
AFTERNOON
.
THAT IS NOT FOUND ANYTHING ON
THE MOUNTAIN TIME AND YOU KNOW
IT MAKES IT REALLY RIGHT ON MY
EYE.
YEAH RIGHT [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH.
YOUR WOOD AND THEN AND THEN
.
YEAH.
RIGHT -- RIGHT YEAH.
WOW.
WELL THE RIGHT [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH [INAUDIBLE]
RIGHT.
REALLY.
RIGHT FROM YOUR HAND ON THE
GROUND YEAH RISING IN THE RIGHT.
YEAH [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH YEAH